this video is about two things the first
is scp096 also known as the shy guy a
horrific monster who murders anyone and
anything unfortunate enough to look at
its face directly or through photos or
videos the second is you because we
asked you for your favorite questions
theories and hypothetical situations
involving
096 we even asked if you thought someone
would be safe from 096 on the moon and
you delivered if you haven't watched our
first video on the infamous shy guy we
recommend checking that out first but
feel free to stick around even if you
haven't first of all let's take a look
at the questions you had about the SCP
foundation's most dangerous introvert
and see if we can't find some answers
how close would you have to be to
trigger it like if it was 5 km away
would it still count the short answer is
that 096 is homicidal rage can be
triggered from pretty much any distance
we'll get get into some of the
potentially crazy extents of this later
on but if you see the shy guy's face
while you're sharing a dimension with
him you're in serious trouble people who
viewed the creature's face in different
countries or even miles underwater have
met gruesome ends 5 km would definitely
not keep you safe what were his Origins
and how strong is he compared to SCP 682
the origins of scp096 are still shrouded
in mystery all we know for sure is that
he was discovered by the foundation in a
snowy mountainous region as for physical
durability he's about even with 682 as
both survived their encounter we know
682 has the psychological advantage
though as 096 has been terrified of the
lizard ever since they met in Cross
testing however you could argue that 096
is technically more dangerous since
unlike 682 096 has never been pacified
before killing its intended target while
on a ramp page if he goes into an
Unstoppable Attack Mode when someone
sees his face shouldn't you not show his
face in the thumbnail thankfully
according to the official documents
artistic representations like paintings
or digitally drawn YouTube thumbnails
have no effect only actual photographs
or videos of the creature can be deadly
so you're safe unless we decide to do a
096 face reveal to celebrate our next
100,000 subscribers of course this leads
us to our next question if it attacks
you when you look at it then how did the
scientist draw the picture of the thing
without looking at it that's a good
question and also one that occurred to
the foundation scientists who came up
with an extremely elaborate solution
they put a d-class tattoo artist inside
a diving bell miles underwater and had
him unseal a photograph of the creature
before drawing a copy this copy was then
released from the diving bell in a
sealed container before 096 inevitably
got to the poor d-class does the shy guy
have to be viewed through a good quality
image to enter a rage State
unfortunately no even the most poorly
rendered or minuscule image of 0 96's
face is a death sentence one of the most
infamous incidents resulted from a man
seeing a small dot that was only a few
pixels wide in a photo from an old ski
trip the dot was 096 taken from a mile
away no true image of 096 is safe
regardless of size in some cannons
despite 096 being referred to as
indestructible the foundation managed to
terminate it after many attempts and
even more bureaucracy how did they do it
well a lot of 0 96's body has been blown
away by conventional arms fire its
hypertough skeleton is what has given it
such an indestructible reputation in one
tail though Foundation researchers
actually used this to their advantage
and employed the use of the next
snapping killer sculpture SCP 173 after
after using 173 to damage 0 96's bones
powerful acid was injected into the
skeleton destroying it from within
though of course this isn't the official
ending of the 096 story because the SCP
Foundation doesn't have a single
unifying cannon that's enough questions
now it's time for you to school us let's
look at some of your favorite theories
about the shy guy starting with I
sometimes like to imagine that 096 is
nice but he can't control when someone
sees him and after he kills the person
he starts to cry because he didn't want
to kill them there is actually some
evidence to suggest that scp096 might
not want to kill a great example of this
is its cross test with SCP 9978 a camera
which reveals the deepest desires of
whoever or whatever is in its photos the
photo it took of 096 showed that it had
completely disappeared from the photo
showing its deepest desire was to just
be invisible and unseen Maybe wants to
disappear because it doesn't want to
hurt anybody regarding the moon question
I think scp096 would probably stay in
that hostile State until you came back
at which point it would promptly rip you
to shreds and do whatever it does to
your mutilated corpse based on what we
know about prior 096 incidents this
feels incredibly likely it's also
possible that it might enter its docile
State before becoming aggressive again
when you return to its murder range you
really don't want to find out either way
way he can just jump to the Moon easy he
does squats in Containment all the time
well it scrawny physique doesn't make it
seem like 096 understands the concept of
exercise there aren't any cameras in 0
96's cell so technically we can't prove
it isn't doing squats to pass the time
in there I really doubt a blind person
would be safe from his effect since 096
has the IQ of a newborn baby I think he
will count it as looking at him this is
an interesting Theory however seeing a
096 is able to sense when people see its
face from entire continents away the way
it knows if you can see its face might
be a little more psychic in nature
therefore it's probable that it wouldn't
mistakenly kill someone who hasn't
actually seen its face such as a person
who is blind to deal with him in my
opinion simply freeze him either in
space or in the mountains his body shuts
down and when looked at it it will not
react correctly it is simply asleep well
we don't know how scp096 will would
react to a zerg environment for a
creature that's always nude it seems
extremely tolerant to the cold when it
was first found it was lurking in icy
mountains and a foundation agent
commented on the fact it wasn't even
shivering despite the incredibly low
temperatures but who knows if there's a
temperature out there that's too low
even for the shy guy if someone looks at
it in China and it's in the US then you
get on its back you'll get a free
piggyback ride to China it's a free trip
to China and all it costs is a human
life that's that's my theory technically
it'd be at the cost of two human lives
unless you wore a diving suit with
plenty of oxygen 096 has proven to be an
extremely proficient swimmer but you'd
have to maintain your grip across the
entire Pacific Ocean while it Journeys
to China in other words it's technically
possible but we here at SCP explained
would rather pay for the roundtrip
flight to each their own though but
that's enough theories for now let's
move on to the main event hypotheticals
you POS some great possible scenarios
involving scp096 so we're going to see
if we can find the answers what would
happen if someone looked at a picture of
it while in or before entering another
scp's pocket Dimension or mirror
Dimension there aren't any Canon
examples to prove either way but if
there's any kind of consistent entry
point into this Dimension it's likely
that 096 would find a way to follow you
in if not it's very possible that it may
just wait for you to eventually return
before bringing the metaphorical hammer
down on you so technically if you were
pulled into the old man's pocket
Dimension and he closed the portal you'd
be safe from 096 but then you've got a
whole other problem to deal with what
happens if a person sees his face then
gets their memory of the creature wiped
considering how good the foundation
seems to be at wiping people's memories
and their access to amnestics if this
worked they probably would have made it
standard procedure by now so it's
unlikely what happens if a person looked
at it and that person then went on a
plane or just staying in the air or
space what would it do 096 has shown the
ability to jump up and Destroy
low-flying aircraft but otherwise it's
likely that the creature would probably
run to a point directly below you and
remain there until you touch back down
since you'll need food and water at some
point and aircrafts need fuel you'd
probably just be prolonging the
inevitable what if the young girl was
around it so it tried to attack her but
died trying this is another interesting
possibility SCP 053 is a girl capable of
causing homicidal urges but causes fatal
heart attacks in those who attack her
while we can't know for sure how a
meeting between 096 and 053 would go we
can use her encounter with 682 as a
potential template aggressive scps like
the hard tokill reptile perhaps having
an innate knowledge of the danger that
comes from attacking 053 tend to become
strangely docile around her it's
possible that 096 would do the same
would we be able to control scp096 with
the help of SCP 035 the possessive mask
AKA SCP 035 is undeniably a lot more
intelligent than 096 and has even been
shown to respond to reason on occasion
it's also been able to control almost
every other entity it's been placed on
the problem is if the mask was placed on
096 and it was somehow effective the
result may be even more dangerous than
096 an intelligent monster with an
indestructible and highly dangerous body
there's no telling whether 035 would
slowly break down 096 into sludge the
way it does to humans in which case we
would be left with an immortal 096 035
combo so maybe it's best that we never
find out if someone were to be in the
infinite Ikea and looked at a picture of
its face could it finally be contained
and if someone else looked at a picture
of it outside of the infinite Ikea could
it escape and kill them if so how long
would it take it this is a great
question and while the infinite Ikea is
a terrifying maze scp096 has an
advantage here that we don't not only
can It Rip through anything in the way
with its super strength it has an innate
sense of where its victim is therefore
regardless of whether you're inside or
out scp096 will still come straight to
you to exact your horrible fate but at
least you can enjoy the meatballs while
you wait right and finally what would
happen if 096 were led into a room full
of mirrors and allowed or made to look
at its own face Would It smash the
mirrors or try to rip itself to pieces
this is still a hotly debated issue to
this day which thanks to the no Canon
nature of the SCP Foundation does not
have a definitive answer some theorize
that this would at least be an effective
deterrent against scp096 While others
suggest that it wouldn't be effective
because many believe that 096 is
actually blind and thus cannot see its
own face it can only sense when other
people see it again we don't quite know
for sure but it's likely to remain one
of the most contentious issues around
the shy guy for a long time to come it's
the late '90s and an Air Canada flight
experiences severe malfunctions while
traveling from London to Vancouver the
pilots are unable to do anything and the
plane crashes into the woods of Northern
Alberta the crash was devastating only
10 of the nearly 300 people on board are
alive and even though they survived the
initial disaster their battle for life
has only just begun it's late autumn in
Northern Canada and there's no telling
when help will arrive if at all if the
survivors want to make it through the
night they need to find shelter and fast
as they trudge through the freezing
Woods the group finds a path that looks
like it might lead them to civilization
after all if there was a path in the
woods that meant they were probably in a
national park and if they were in a
national park there had to be a ranger
station around somewhere where they
could warm up and call for help they
didn't have many other options so they
followed the path which opened up to a
clearing but instead of finding a ranger
station or Campground they found
something none of them could have
expected Ed it was a pond but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange Pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird algy or chemical reaction
but one member of the group a man named
Thomas Dean who had been on his way back
to his hometown of Prince George British
Columbia thought there was something
strangely familiar about this he
remembered being a boy and going to
visit family in Alberta and hearing an
urban legend from the older local kids
according to the stories somewhere out
in the wilderness in the northern part
of the province there was a pond full of
human blood and what made it even worse
was that some said the pond was a
gateway to Hell the SCP Foundation was
also aware of this Legend and had been
trying to pinpoint the exact source of
it for decades prior to the Air Canada
crash they would finally receive
definite confirmation of the blood Pond
when Foundation Personnel intercepted a
radio transmission from a ranger station
located within the Wood Buffalo national
park it was the survivors of the crash
who had managed to make it through the
night and they were about to be escorted
out of the park by Rangers the
foundation mobilized quickly to cordon
off the pond as at the time they were
unsure of what potentially harmful
properties the pond might have had they
set up watch station Epsilon 38 and put
staff on guard to deter travelers from
the area the pond was given the
designation of SCP 354 and classed as
uid Foundation scientists made a number
of interesting discoveries about SCP 354
when they collected samples for testing
first the pond was not in fact full of
blood merely an inorganic liquid that
closely resembles blood in color and
consistency second and even Stranger
Than The Red liquid is that the pond
doesn't seem to have any definite Banks
or a bottom instead the liquid in the
pond increases in density as the radius
away from the center increases the
liquid congeals at the edges become
becoming more solid and blending into
the surrounding soil it also becomes
thicker as one descends deeper into the
pool and the bottom of the pond has not
yet been reached if it even exists
initially the foundation found no signs
of life within the blood Pond but that
would all change at 2:03 p.m. on the day
following the opening of Watch Station
Epsilon 38 when the science team noticed
an unusual level of activity on the
Pond's surface security footage feed
showed a shape rising out of the pond
followed by a deafening shriek after
that the feed was cut and Foundation
lost all communication with watch
station Epsilon 38 fearing the worst a
mobile task force was dispatched to the
location when they got there all
Personnel at the watch station had been
killed by what could only be described
as a gigantic bat the task force was
able to neutralize the entity and as
soon as they could the foundation moved
in to increase security around the SCP
creating area 354 and installing a
permanent security detail after this
point the pond started to regularly spit
out a variety of monstrous entities
almost as if it was reacting to the SCP
foundation's increased security measures
after SCP 3541 the giant bat came SCP
3542 3542 was an a kidal likee monster
the size of a bear that was virtually
bulletproof but unable to escape area
354 the foundation neutralized this
anomaly with Napal SCP 3543 was a
floating black sphere capable of firing
deadly beams of concentrated energy the
area's head scientist was able to hit it
with a sledgehammer causing the sphere
to malfunction and self-destruct before
it was able to escape the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with SCP
3544 this creature was a reptilian
humanoid that stood roughly 15 ft tall
and was unable to be put down with
gunfire this was the first Creature from
the pond to successfully Escape
containment and was only able to be
neutralized when the foundation sent in
Mobile task force Omega 7 also known as
Pandora's Box the data on Pond
incursions is partially corrupted so a
complete list of creatures is not
available but some of the other monsters
that came out of the blood Pond include
a killer robot a set of gigantic
tentacles that drag several d-class
Personnel into the pond a pair of
panther-like creatures one made of ice
and the other of magma that ignored
Foundation staff and instead fought each
other and one seemingly normal human man
who was executed as soon as he emerged
from the pond tests on his body revealed
that he was in fact totally normal and
would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months the head
scientist at the time noted I suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or powered down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through ofi believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30% of our total personnel and cut 25%
of our funding while I can only hope
that they are correct if the latter
situation is true we're soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it I worry for all of our
safety his words would prove eily
prophetic following the events of
exploratory Mission 354 Alpha the
foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to
explore the pond because of the strange
properties of the Pond's density the
craft was essentially made to be both a
submarine for parts of the pond where
the contents were liquid and a drill for
when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
Swanson agent turquoise agent 86 Dr J
MacArthur Chris Simmons Leroy Tucker and
a pilot named Martin with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happened for
the first 2 days of the mission but at
4:30 a.m. on the 3D day gravity suddenly
reversed for the crew of the ship this
seemed to indicate that they were
approaching the halfway point though
what would be on the other side nobody
could say on the fourth day the ship
surfac proving definitely that the pond
was in fact some sort of portal the crew
looked out of the port holes to see the
darkness of night above them while
sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting the
craft the other side of the pond was
nothing like the world the crew knew for
one thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before Dawn came and and when the Sun
finally Rose it was much larger and
redder than the Earth's sun under the
light of the strange red star the crew
could see that the pond on this side was
massive compared to what they've come
into more like a large lake surrounding
the lake was sand and rocks that were
covered in a kind of moss that
disappeared under sunlight and regrew
during the night the team left the ship
and started to explore during their time
in This Strange World they found that
the day lasted just a few hours shorter
than the night meaning meaning that
whatever Planet they were on had a
roughly 43h hour long rotation as
opposed to our own planets 24 the team
found a number of anomalous elements on
their expedition including razor sharp
grass that can puncture skin and streams
of liquid carbon dioxide they heard some
loud Roars in the distance once or twice
but other than that the planet was
eerily silent with seemingly no animal
life and not even wind when it rained
the soil remained dry and based on that
the scientist theorized the plants in
this world were more efficient at
absorbing moisture on the 25th day the
team ran into a huge metal wall that
appeared to be artificially constructed
luckily Leroy Tucker a quick- thinking
researcher was able to rig a blowtorch
from camping supplies and melt a hole
through the metal on the other side
there was finally wind and odd black
grass that's the extent of what is known
about the other side of the wall because
the Expedition logs are heavily
corrupted after that point but we know
that whatever was in there wasn't good
because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other Expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
date a year following the discovery of
the blood Pond and construction of area
354 the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhe head
was detonated completely destroying the
site MTF Theta 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated area
354 it was apparent that there had been
some kind of mutiny within the site and
that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the Convoy totally
annihilated MTF Theta 12 and no further
contact with a former Personnel of area
354 has been made since following the
site's detonation a new site was
constructed called simply the red pool
containment site unlike the previous
facility which focused on research and
neutralization the new site is entirely
concerned with containment the shift and
directive came as a response to the
Pond's apparent reactive nature each
creature that emerged from the pond
seemed to be in retaliation to the
foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the Mutiny at
area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself an
interview in the SCP file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous
attempt to control and understand the
blood Pond according to an interview
with a foundation agent the head doctor
proposed a scheme to drain the blood
Pond using a system of pumps and hoses
all non-essential Personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency leaving
only the pump technicians d-class
personnel and a few agents for security
however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the side experienced a mass dissociative
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being being
in a dream and suddenly realizing that
you're asleep he said everything stopped
being real it was like we had to Escape
right now when asked what happened when
the pump was turned on he simply
explained that it wouldn't let them this
interview confirmed the theory that the
pond is not only capable of releasing
monsters out into our world but also
that it's capable of powerful but much
more subtle psychological attacks this
suggests a chilling possibility that the
pond isn't just blindly reacting to
being attacked but it's fully sentient
and the actions of the SCP Foundation
have only served to annoy it and worst
studies of the pwns banks have proved
evidence that the area of congealed
liquid around the perimeter of the pond
has been steadily expanding that's right
the pond is getting bigger the last
thing the foundation agent stationed at
the site said before being dragged out
of the interview and sedated was it gets
bigger and stronger every day and now
we've made it Angry a bright flash of
light awakens p rro Wilson from his
vegetative state he sits up and brushes
the sand off himself looking around the
desolate desert he's found himself in
how did he get here the last thing he
remembers is uncovering secret orders
from the leaders of the SCP Foundation
just before they declared war on
Humanity unfortunately the most
important parts of the files had been
redacted now he's on a mission to
finally discover why the SCP Foundation
is trying to kill every last human on
the planet but there is something else
he has to deal with first what happened
Petro says out loud as he looks at his
vitals in the heads up display of SCP
5000 he is still contained within the
exclusionary suit that makes him
undetectable to human senses he checks
the date and gasps in Surprise 3 months
I've been passed out for 3
months he stands up and looks across the
barren landscape the screen inside the
suit indicates that he has traversed
half of the country since he left site
19 3 months ago Petra looked down at one
of his hands he is holding a leather
briefcase where did that come from he
wonders Petro has no idea what is inside
the briefcase but he knows it definitely
isn't round he tries to let go his
fingers won't open he uses his other
hand to try and pry the briefcase away
from himself but his hand only clasps to
it harder then a wave of calm washes
over him something inside his head
speaks to him but it's not a voice more
like a feeling it is a sense of purpose
and Petro's new Miss in life is to
deliver this briefcase to SCP
579 nothing else is as important Petra
Wilson takes a deep breath and Embraces
his new purpose in life he still wants
to uncover the reason that the SCP
Foundation is trying to wipe out
Humanity but this will have to wait
until he delivers the briefcase to SCP
579 Petro doesn't know exactly where 579
is located but he can feel a pull in a
certain direction so he begins to walk
Petro brings up the information stored
in the SCP 5000 suit from the
foundation's
database he finds that all information
about what SCP 579 is has been expunged
from the record the only useful
information in the file is that the ker
level SCP is located at site
62c at least Petro has a destination to
aim for he travels for days without
seeing a living soul but he does pass
thousands of corpses he tries to ignore
them but one stands out to him inside a
house as he searches for
supplies it's the body of a recently
deceased boy he couldn't have been more
than 8 years old he was so young Petra
thinks he bends over to scoop up the
body and bury it outside as his hand
touches the body the boy's skin begins
to move it is as if hundreds of tiny
creatures are scurrying just under the
skin then from out of every orifice
comes hundreds of little pale worms each
with the face of the boy they are all
cackling as they crawl out of the boy's
body and into a drain a few feet away
Petro jumps back and runs this is the
last person I try to bury he thinks
Petro pushes forward the hundreds of
little laughing worms haunting his
thoughts until he puts a significant
distance between himself and the little
boy's body Petro continues to walk
towards the direction of site 62c he
passes more corpses but decides to stay
clear of them although the suit makes it
so Petro doesn't need to rest he can
only go so fast he enters a small
abandoned town that looks like something
out of an old western movie a tumble
weed blows across the dirt road Petro
sits on the wooden step of the local
Saloon and takes a break he looks down
at the briefcase in his hand he hasn't
had the urge to open it only to deliver
it to SCP 579 Petro puts the briefcase
on his lap he stares at it and slides
his hands along the leather stops with
his thumb on the latch and pushes the
locks snap open Petro opens the
briefcase a bright light beams out and
he passes
out when Petro comes to again he is
miles closer to site 62c there is a warm
feeling enveloping his body he looks
down at the briefcase which is now
closed wow this thing is like my own
personal skip button Petro thinks he
holds up the briefcase unlatches the
locks sees the bright light and passes
out again he awakes once again miles
away from his last position so it wasn't
just a one-off effect Petro continues
walking across the country switching
between using his own legs and whatever
magic is contained within the briefcase
he is making faster progress now as he
walks through a dense deciduous forest
he comes across a pack of wolves eating
the remains of an SCP agent Petro is
undetectable to the Wolves thanks to the
SCP 5000 suit and he makes his way over
to the pack quietly grabbing a laptop
laying on the ground next to the agent's
body Petro takes the laptop and goes
away deeper into the forest before
stopping to boot up the computer he has
not forgotten about the horrors the SCP
Foundation has released and he needs to
know how the world has been doing over
the last few months what he finds is not
good the SCP Foundation has triggered
the eruption of Yellowstone destroying
SCP 2000 which unknown to Pietro
contained the fail safe for rebuilding
Human Society in the event of a
world-ending scenario which this was
starting to look more and more like it
was only a matter of time now before the
soot and Ash thrown up by the eruption
blocks out the sun in much of what is
left of the United States the foundation
has also found a way to get SCP 2241 to
do their dirty work at refugee camps the
young brown-haired boy is most likely
being manipulated by the foundation
under the pretense that they're only
doing what is best for their child he
has caused whole groups of refugees to
turn on each other leading to a massacre
the last entry says that the young boy
is being sent to the global ult
Coalition hold out in genzer to help
destroy some of the last threats to the
SCP Foundation a series of other scps
have been dispatched by the foundation
around the world to continue the
destruction of humanity they even
managed to use temporal anomalies to
make it Christmas time everywhere around
the world so SCP
4666 the brutal U tide creature that
stalks the homes of children is free to
cause
chaos Petro had seen enough he slams the
laptop shut throws it against the trunk
of a tree and opens the briefcase again
he awakes standing feet away from a
group of global ult Coalition soldiers
who are sitting around a campfire maybe
they know why the SCP Foundation is
trying to end the world he thinks he
decides that it is too risky to show
himself to the soldiers but takes some
solace in sitting around the campfire
with other living humans the soldiers
are sharing stories about what is
happening one catches the attention of
Petro Wilson it is strange but also May
hold a clue as to why the SCP Foundation
is trying to wipe out Humanity one of
the soldiers recounts an event that he
witnessed before leaving the global oul
coalition's headquarters at genzer they
had just captured an SCP Soldier trying
to break into the base the infiltrator
name was Samuel Ross he had been
strapped into an interrogation chair and
questioned the interviewers were not
getting anywhere until Ross was
threatened with torture to which he
responded do what you want once you
realize you're not supposed to feel pain
there's nothing to be afraid of anymore
Petro sits up straight and starts to
listen more intently he remembers
stumbling across SCP soldiers on his way
to site 19 that exhibited the same no
pain mentality that this Samuel Ross
seems to have after that odd statement
by Samuel Ross there was the sound of
wind it started slow at first then
ramped up until it was howling like a
hurricane that's when the screaming
started the screams became louder and
climbed to a higher pitch then the room
went dead silent the last thing that
Samuel Ross said was look what you've
done to yourselves I told you you
wouldn't like it didn't you that's why
you hear your voice but you wanted to
know so badly I really liked you guys
eyes so I was trying to be nice we're so
kind to you you know we fight in the
light so you can die in the
dark
disgusting Petro sits back on his
hunches and rocks back and forth he has
an ominous feeling that there is a
connection between the missing pain of
the SCP soldiers and the reason why the
foundation declared war on Humanity the
soldier who told the story of of Samuel
Ross stands up after that interview is
when the destruction of ganir Started
From The Inside it is why the global oul
Coalition is no more God help us all the
soldier finished with the story turns
from the others and starts to walk away
as the soldier makes his way towards the
woods Petro Can just barely make out
that he's taken his pistol from his
tolster before he disappears into the
darkness the world truly has gone mad
Petro opens the briefcase and blacks out
Petro sluggishly continues his walk he's
moving down a rocky path in the middle
of the forest and his will to keep going
is slowly being drained the only reason
he has not sat down and given up is
because of the driving urge to get the
briefcase to
579 he wants so badly to concentrate and
discover the reason that the foundation
released the scps on Humanity but the
need to reach 579 won't let him focus on
anything else he's noticed though that
every time he opens the briefcase to
skip ahead he makes less and less
progress the warm feeling of the first
few transports has been replaced by a
nauseated headache every time he comes
out of the trance Petro exits the forest
into an open field the wind blows across
the high grass looking like green waves
and standing scattered throughout the
field are statues as Petro approaches he
sees that they are statues of mobile
task force Foundation
soldiers he slowly walks closer to the
White marble statues he reach is the
first one and looks at the face of the
Frozen Soldier his eyes have been
scooped Out All That Remains are black
empty sockets the arms of the soldier
have been carved into blades like a
praying mantis he walks past the first
statue and proceeds to the next one
where he hears something move in the
grass behind him he spins around to look
at the Statue he could have sworn it was
in a slightly different position no
that's crazy Petra thinks he continues
to the next statue it is another carving
of an MTF Soldier no eyes blades for
arms this is really creepy Petro says
aloud he proceeds through the field he
walks up a slight Hill and turns around
to look at the field of statues what he
sees is terrifying the statues have all
moved and are now in different
positions it appears as if they were
slashing through the area looking for
something or someone Petro continu over
the hill and comes Upon A group of
refugees they are picking through the
field looking for food to eat a fog
begins to move in it is being swept
across the meadow by the wind Petra
watches from a distance as the fog
envelops the small group suddenly there
is screaming and the sound of blades
going through flesh the screams cease
almost immediately Petro runs down the
hill to where the refugees were the fog
lifts the group of people have been cut
to Pieces standing standing in the
middle of the Carnage is one of the MTF
Soldier statues blood dripping from its
blade
arms Petro knows what to do he runs
after a few miles Petro slows to catch
his breath those statues must have been
created by the foundation he thinks it's
as if they are frozen in place but as
soon as you take your eyes off them they
can move with killer speed even in the
suit my eyesight can stop them but they
can't see me they must know I'm there
though since they can't move Petra
Wilson opens the briefcase once again
for what he didn't know would be the
last time when he comes to this time he
is near sight 62c he can feel himself
being pulled stronger than ever in the
direction of his destination he walks
down a deserted Road past the husks of
burnt vehicles and at the end is the
gate to site
62c there are no guards or security of
any kind it looks like the site has been
abandoned for a long time and the gate
is wide open beckoning Petra Wilson in
into site 62c where SCP 579
Waits Petra Wilson enters the dark
hallway he somehow knows leads down into
the Crypt of site 62c the walls drip
with what he hopes is water from leaking
pipes but it has a metallic smell and is
much too red to actually be water he
begins to feel nauseous it gets harder
to breathe even the SCP 5000 suit can't
keep him calm he turns and runs back up
the stairs out of site 62c Petro begins
to Sab
uncontrollably as the memories of
everything that has happened over the
past several months suffocates his will
to go on then as if an invisible force
that refuses to let him go takes control
Petro feels as if a gun has been shoved
into the small of his back he is being
sent back into site 62c whether he wants
to go or not he is unsure if what is
forcing him back into the base is inside
the briefcase his own uncontrollable
urge to know what is going on or SCP 579
itself but he cannot stop himself from
re-entering the doorway and proceeding
into site
62c he doesn't know what SCP 579 looks
like but Petro has a Sinister feeling
that it is watching him he reaches the
bottom of the stairway and proceeds down
a dark hallway the power went out a long
time ago and the only light in the
depths of site 62c is the dim glow
coming from the helmet of the SC P 5000
suit Petro notices long gashes along the
concrete walls as if someone took a
giant knife and dragged it from one end
of the hallway to the other there is
something at the end of the corridor
that Petro can't make out as he gets
closer the lights on the SCP 5000 suit
begin to flicker the thing at the end of
the hallway seems to move slightly each
time the lights on the suit dim the
lights on the suit go out completely and
the entire hallway is plunged Into
Darkness only for for a second though
and when the lights come back on a
statue of an MTF Soldier looms over
Petro its eyes are empty sockets its
lips are turned up in a snarl the arms
have been filed into blades no Petro
screams he Dodges around the statue the
moment it is out of his sight he hears
the sound of blades on concrete as the
statue of the soldier comes to life and
begins slashing its way down the hallway
it cannot see Petro but it knows he is
there it slashes all around trying to
connect with whoever is there with it
Petro runs to the end of the hallway and
reaches the door he presses against the
heavy metal door to open straining
against its weight all while the blind
statue is still slashing coming closer
and closer the door is almost open but
then Petro feels a blade lacerate the
back of the suit cutting deeply into the
skin of his back missing his spinal cord
by millimeters another blade enters
through the back of his shoulder
piercing straight through he somehow
pulls himself through the crack doorway
way and kicks the metal door shut behind
him he can hear the banging and scraping
of blades outside the metal door the
creature has not given up and is trying
to break in Petro turns around to see he
is in an observation chamber full of
instruments and screens blood runs down
his back from the wounds inflicted by
the statue he walks slowly over to the
window on the desk in front of him is a
file labeled SCP
579 he looks through the observation
glass and down into the chamber below it
is too dark to make anything out but
Petro Can Feel That SCP 579 is down
there looking up at him Petro looks to
his left and sees a hole in the floor he
walks over and looks down and leads
right into the containment chamber of
579 let's get this over with Petro says
out loud he holds the briefcase over the
hole and tries to open his hand his
finger won't budge SCP 579 wants him to
hand deliver the briefcase Petro Wilson
takes a deep breath closes his eyes and
steps into the opening of the hole he
falls in the moments before he lands in
SCP 579 containment Chamber Something
comes to him he realizes that he isn't
going to be a hero he isn't going to
figure out why the SCP Foundation is
trying to wipe out humanity and he isn't
going to
survive he lands hard on the ground
below it is completely dark except for a
shadow that moves in the corner of the
containment chamber Petra Wilson creates
one last
if anyone ever reads this please please
figure out why explain it to me someone
anyone I don't get it I just don't get
it SCP 579 steps into the glow that the
SCP 5000 suit is giving off Petra Wilson
looks up at it oh so that's how it
is he says before SCP 5000 creates its
final log life signs lost Vital Signs
lost SCP 5000 appeared in a flash of
light in the containment chamber of SCP
579 located in site 62c the researchers
monitoring SCP 579 had no idea where the
suit came from or why contained the body
of Petra Wilson a foundation employee
who is assigned to site 06 and is very
much alive Wilson appears who have no
knowledge of SCP 5000 or memories of the
events logged in SCP 5000's data banks
although the suit is believed to have
been capable at one point of a number of
anomalous functions and abilities the
damage it has sustained has rendered it
inoperable except for the storage of
data files which now have been archived
and stored on secure Foundation servers
stop me if you've heard this one before
a young man was driving home from work
late one rainy night when he spotted a
woman in a white dress and a red sweater
walking along the shoulder of the road
concerned for her safety he slowed down
and rolled down the window so he could
talk to her when he asked where she was
going she said she was walking to her
parents' house the man pulled over and
offered her a ride that she accepted the
woman gave him the address of her home
hopped in the back seat and the man
drove off he sensed that she must have
been cold from walking in the rain so he
cranked up the car's heater to help her
dry off soon she removed her heavy red
sweater and placed it on the seat next
to her the man tried to make friendly
conversation asking if the woman had a
job what she was studying at school
where'd she been that day but she
remained quiet staring out the window
until they drove past an old graveyard
the woman began pounding on the glass of
the car as if she desperately wanted
something unsure of what to do the man
pulled over but before he could ask her
what was happening she had gotten out of
the car he exited the car to try and
find her but the woman was nowhere to be
seen she must have somehow ran off
confused the man got back in his car and
drove away he went on his way and didn't
think of it again until the next day
when he noticed her sweater was still in
the back of his car he decided to go to
the house she had originally given him
the address for and give it back to her
he found the home without any trouble
but when he knocked on the door the old
woman who answered it was confused by
his story she told him that her daughter
couldn't have possibly left her sweater
in his car because she died in a car
accident 30 years ago the vanishing
hitchhiker is a classic ghost story with
the details varying from place to place
and Storyteller to Storyteller in
Chicago she goes by Resurrection Mary
named after the graveyard she asks for
rides to in okanawa Japan she's known as
the night walker of Nago and she only
appears to taxi drivers in Kent England
she's Suzanne a bride killed in a car
wreck on the way to her bachelorette
party in North Carol Carolina her name
is Lydia and in Hawaii she's believed to
be the goddess Pelle in human form but
as far as our friends at the SCP
Foundation are concerned the vanishing
hitchhiker's name is Mary talish also
known as SCP
1337 on the 19th of May 1952 College
sophomore Mary talish was abducted on
her way to class in her hometown of Muny
Indiana when police found her body 2
weeks later her eyes and heart had been
torn from her body in a ritualist
fashion and she had scrapes and bruises
that suggested she had been beaten
before her murder her killers were never
caught and her body was returned to her
family for burial in tomance in Cemetery
starting on the 19th of June that same
year someone matching Mary's description
a Caucasian woman with blonde hair
standing 150 cm tall and wearing a red
sweater was spotted trying to fly down
passing Vehicles along Mayflower Road
since then every month on the 19th
Mary has been cited along that stretch
of road and every month the same
scenario plays out Mary gives anyone who
picks her up directions to her parents'
house then on the way she instructs the
driver to stop at the graveyard where
she was buried she vanishes from the car
leaving her sweater the driver of the
car tries to return the sweater to her
parents' house only to be told that Mary
talish was dead when the SCP Foundation
was made aware of Mary tales's pattern
of Haunting in the late 50s they set up
a system system where agents would
Patrol Mayflower Road at hourly
intervals with the intention of picking
Mary up agents were sent on their own in
non-foundation cars and instructed to
stick to the accepted script of the
vanishing hitchhiker Legend without
attempting to engage Mary in further
conversation Mary's parents were also
given E-class agent status to keep them
from speaking about the haunting and
told that the foundation was working on
a way to set the spirit to rest early
attempts to study The Apparition were
inconclusive
it proved impossible for the foundation
to relocate her or trigger her
manifestation outside of the 19th of
every month an attempts to analyze her
sweater were fruitless since if the
sweater wasn't returned to the talish
family home it would simply vanish from
containment at or around sunset on the
next 19th for 20 years SCP 1337 events
continued to happen as normal d-class
Personnel under the instruction of the
foundation would pick Mary up drive her
past the cemetery and return her sweater
to her parents it was business as usual
and in fact it was one of the more
sedate reoccurring apparitions the
foundation had to deal with but as you
might have guessed that piece wouldn't
last forever enter Dr Lawson who in 1972
was placed in charge of all resources
regarding SCP
1337 Dr Lawson was getting sick of all
this Phantom hitchhiker business and
while most of the foundation was happy
to keep this routine going Lawson
thought that the continual picking up
and dropping off of Mary talish and her
red sweater was a waste of the
foundation's valuable time after all it
was the early '70s the price of oil was
at an all-time high so the expense of
sending car after car up and down the
same road for a solid day once a month
just to pick up a ghost was more trouble
than it was worth so Lawson started
developing a plan one that he didn't go
through the proper Foundation channels
to approve he reason that the reason
Mary's ghost kept coming back was
because she wanted something since
always asked for a ride home then it
must mean she wanted to return back to
her parents so logic followed that if
she had nothing or no one to go back to
then she'd stop appearing on the 18th of
June 1973 Lawson went ahead with his
plan without his superior's knowledge
and ordered the execution of Mary
tales's parents as well as the immediate
demolition of their family home
according to his journals Lawson had
hoped that his attempt at
decommissioning 1337 would significantly
cut the foundation's gas bills freeing
up valuable funds at which point he'd
surely be promoted in recognition of his
Brilliance but that wasn't what happened
Lawson was demoted from team leader to
junior staff and only kept on 1337
detail out of the belief that without a
family to return to Lawson would become
the new focal point of The Haunting
should Mary talish ever return the
Lawson's actions weren't at all above
board even by a SCP Foundation standards
they did seem to have worked the 19th of
June came and went without a single Mar
sighting and she wasn't seen the next
month either a full year went by without
any sign of the Mayflower Road
Apparition satisfied with this turn of
events the foundation made the decision
to officially reclassify SCP 1337 from
safe to Safe decommissioned and the gas
money that was budgeted for the
Mayflower Road Patrol was redirected to
the SCP 682 tank acid fund but even
though everything seemed to have been
sorted out Lawson wasn't entirely
satisfied and not just because of his
demotion whether it was Intuition or
merely guilt induced paranoia is unclear
but he suspected that Mary was still out
there somewhere at first he thought that
she might show up on the anniversary of
her parents' deaths but then that date
came and went as did eight more
anniversaries after it finally on the
19th of June 1983 Lawson decided he had
to see for himself fitted with recording
equipment he drove alone in a
non-foundation standard car down that
lonely stretch of road where so many
before him had stopped to pick up that
mysterious blonde woman with the red
sweater he had to prove to himself that
she wouldn't show up that he had really
and truly gotten rid of her for good it
was about 5:00 in the evening when he
reached Mayflower Road at first he
didn't experience anything strange he
scanned the roadside looking for the
Phantom hitchhiker walking along it but
there was nobody there Dr Lawson
breathed a sigh of relief he may have
orchestrated the deaths of two innocent
people but at least it hadn't been for
nothing he turned on the recorder he
brought with him and logged that nothing
had happened SCP 1337 had been
permanently neutralized as he approached
the T intersection and prepared to turn
onto Marsh Avenue he looked up to adjust
his rearview mirror to his horror he
found that he wasn't alone in the car
someone was in the seat behind him
someone with blonde hair and a red
sweater his last transmission consisted
only of wait who the hell are you before
the recording abruptly stopped Lawson's
car was found soon after by Foundation
agents lawon was dead in the front seat
bruised and bloody with his eyes and
heart ripped out in a ritualistic
fashion just the way Mary talish had
been found all the way back in
1952 it turns out that Mary hadn't been
neutral ized after all she'd just been
waiting for a chance to get revenge on
the man who killed her family and Mary
didn't stop with Dr Lawson no longer
does she appear walking along the road
waiting for someone to offer her a ride
before disappearing without incident now
should someone pass by without offering
a ride she will appear in their back
seat before reenacting the method of her
own death upon the driver and her
physical appearance has changed too
whereas before she looked like the image
of a pretty young woman before her
tragedy now recording show that she
appears with the wounds of her death
present her eyes gouged out in their
sockets and a massive hole in her chest
where her heart should be the same
wounds she inflicts on her victims the
SCP Foundation has tried closing off and
eventually destroying the road but that
has only resulted in Mary manifesting at
other locations in and around Muny
Foundation documents reveal that any
Back Road in the city can potentially
serve as host to a 13 19 37 event and
all attempts to contain The Apparition
have failed the only way someone who has
seen Mary can avoid her wrath is by
stopping to pick her up at which point
she will dematerialize before
reappearing on another road mobile task
forces have been unsuccessful as Mary
only appears to those driving alone and
all agents who have been sent on solo
missions to apprehend her have resulted
in the death of the agent SC SCP 1337
was reinstated this time as uclid class
currently the foundation's method of
managing SCP 1337 is to dispatch a
security team on the 19th of every month
to monitor all the places where a
potential sighting could take place as
soon as signs of a manifestation are
identified a remotely controlled vehicle
containing a single declass is driven to
the location once Mary appears in the
car the car is piloted to the empty lot
where her home used to stand and the
remains of the d-class are then disposed
of like a lot of the stories that could
pass down as urban legends the story of
SCP 1337 has a lesson that can be taken
away from it this SCP started off as an
ordinary local haunting no more deadly
than Lydia Suzanne Resurrection Mary or
any of the countless other local
versions of the vanishing hitchhiker
story but thanks to one Rogue Foundation
doctor and his desire to rush what he
thought would be an efficient solution
the spirit not only became harder to
control but also much more violent and
bloodthirsty than anyone was prepared to
deal with so if there's anything we can
learn here it's that no matter if you're
a student an office worker or a
researcher with the SCP Foundation think
twice about cutting Corners it might
save you a little bit of time and money
in the short term but in the long term
the results could be fatal the year was
1983 and 7-year-old Andrea Bradbury was
wandering the streets of Nashville
Tennessee one of her favorite activities
was to head down to the local movie
theater and fantasize about the movie
she'd one day be old enough to see this
fateful weekend Andrea's local theater
was playing a brand new release jaws 3D
what she didn't know is that this simple
innocent activity would bring little
Andrea into dangerous contact with SCP
178 and change her life forever jaws 3D
isn't exactly a classic it was one of
the many forgettable sequel pumped out
to cash in on the 3D craze of the early
1980s people paid extra for the
privilege of sitting in the dark with an
uncomfortable pair of cardboard glasses
while cheesy effects leapt out of the
screen towards them many of the movie
goers simply threw away the cheap
disposable glasses as soon as they left
the theater leaving them scattered on
the sidewalk outside seeing a pair of 3D
glasses on the ground right there for
the taking was the highlight of little
Andrea's week she may not have been old
enough to see any of the movies
but she knew that a local shop sold
books with images that popped out of the
page with a simple pair of 3D glasses
excited by the prospect of getting to
experience 3D Andrea grabbed a pair of
glasses and ran straight for the
bookstore later that night she was in
her bedroom with a stereoscopic image of
a ferris wheel Andrea adjusted the
glasses and the ferris wheel really did
pop right off the page she marveled at
the image coming out of the book and
felt like she could almost touch it but
suddenly a strange feeling came over her
she had the feeling that she wasn't
alone still wearing the glasses Andrea
looked up from her book and saw it
standing in the corner of her room
something huge something
monstrous Andrea's parents heard her
scream and came rushing into her room
there was their little girl dead it
looked like she'd been mauled to death
by a wild animal but there was no sign
of her killer the windows were shut shut
tight unable to be opened from the
outside it was like whatever horrible
creature had done this had vanished Into
Thin Air the coroner's report didn't
give any other Clues as to who could
have done this except that whoever or
whatever had murdered her it appeared to
have three long and Incredibly sharp
claws the terrible tragedy of Andrea's
death rocked Nashville but it never made
the national papers why because the SCP
Foundation was immediately on the case
Undercover agents in the US fish and
wildlife service flagged the strange
death as anomalous and SCP field
Personnel arrived to do their own
investigation of the crime scene there
they quickly discovered Andrea's 3D
glasses which would eventually be
classified as SCP
178 an agent looked over the glasses
there didn't seem to be anything out of
the ordinary about them just your
regular cardboard frames with blue and
red tinted film over the eyes everything
about them seemed normal so he tried the
glasses on for himself he picked up the
open book off the ground where Andrea
had likely dropped it and saw the ferris
wheel pop off the page nothing abnormal
until he turned his head slightly he saw
the head of some kind of thing only an
inch away from his own looking over his
shoulder at the book being a trained SCP
agent he maintained his composure and
looked around the room as he did he saw
that several other creatures were
standing in one watch ing none of the
rest of the recovery team seemed to
notice the creatures and when the agent
removed SCP 178 they vanished it
appeared they had found whatever had
caused Andrea Bradbury's death the
glasses were immediately taken to the
nearest Foundation containment site for
further testing seeing these mysterious
entities through SCP 178 may have
answered one question but it raised many
others what are these creatures were
they real or merely Illusions created by
a CP P
178 if they are real are they somehow
summoned by SCP 178 or simply revealed
by them there was already one death that
could be tied to the glasses with some
certainty but just how dangerous were
they the SCP Foundation was about to
find out Foundation scientists devised a
series of experiments with a test
chamber separated from an adjoining
observation chamber by a panel of
reinforced bulletproof glass a member of
d-class personnel was placed into the
test chamber along with SCP 178 he was
instructed to put on the glasses and
report back what he saw to the
researchers the d-class followed the
orders however when he did so he quickly
entered a state of extreme distress he
threw away the glasses and covered his
eyes screaming wildly when ordered to
compose himself and explain what he saw
under threat of termination the d-class
described a hideous creature standing
close to his face watching when asked to
elaborate he described it as having too
many
eyes after that the d-class refused to
put the glasses back on again despite
direct orders and threats from
Foundation staff he was then removed
from the test chamber and observed
although he experienced 2 days of mild
paranoia after 30 total days of
observation the d-class was found to
have no lasting psychological effects
disappointed by the meager results of
the first test the researchers had at
least confirmed that they did have an
anomalous object in their possession
impressed on with experimentation they
used the same methodology again on
another DCL class she was placed into
the chamber and instructed to put on SCP
178 then described The Entity she saw in
great detail when she put on the glasses
she recoiled in horror at the monster
she saw staring back at her she said
that the creature was tall and bipedal
with two additional upper appendages
ending in large conical protrusions she
also described the creature's head as
being smooth when asked if the creature
exhibited any kind of aggress ression or
hostility she said that it was
completely still it was just standing
there after a few minutes though the
creatures seemed to lose interest and
begin staring at the wall the
researchers were happy to learn more
about the creatures physicality but they
still weren't confident that it wasn't
just an illusion created by the glasses
they needed to engineer an interaction
for the next experiment they decided to
alter the particulars a fractal blue and
red image in a similar style to the
stereoscopic Ferris wheel from the book
Andrea had purchased was fixed to one
wall against the opposite wall they
placed a bucket containing 10 standard
tennis balls this time the d-class a
convicted murderer and arsonist was told
he was helping to test a new 3D
augmented reality project the entities
he would see as far as he knew were
little more than digital projections
though when he actually wore SCP 178 and
saw them he commented that whoever
designed them must be crazy the
researchers and instructed the d-class
to pick up a tennis ball and throw it at
one of the entities the second he did so
deep lacerations began appearing all
over his body the onslaught was brutal
and quick and the d-class was dead soon
after that this confirmed to the
researchers that the creatures did seem
to have some level of tangible presence
and they could be extremely violent if
provoked next they wish to see if it was
possible to have any kind of interaction
with the creatures without it
immediately descending into violence to
test this Theory the researchers brought
a 19-year-old declass into the testing
chamber under the same pretense of
testing new 3D
technology much like the others she was
still horrified by the appearance of the
creatures but was calmed down by the
researchers they asked her to speak to
the creatures directly without
exhibiting any kind of aggression she
said hello weird thing how are you today
in a somewhat bored voice and this was
all it took to sign her death warrant
she was immediately slashed to death by
invisible creatures the results seemed
clear any interaction whatsoever with
the creatures while wearing SCP 178 was
a death sentence like a slightly more
outgoing shy guy but the researchers
would soon find that this anomaly had
even more
surprises for their next test they
brought in two subjects one would wear
SCP 178 and dictate to the other how
they should interact with the creature
they could not see the results of this
experiment were bloody yet informative
both subjects were slashed to death when
the unseeen d-class interacted with one
of the creatures on her companion's
instructions it appeared that anyone
with sufficient knowledge of the
creatures who attempts to interact with
them is doomed even if they can't
directly see one of them it was an
upsetting realization for the
researchers SCP 178 may be much more
dangerous than they initially imagined
and what they learn in the next
experiment was even worse they adopted
the same methodology as the last for the
following experiment two subjects one
seeing and the other interacting however
this time as soon as subject number one
put on the glasses they knew that
something was terribly wrong he began
panicking stating that the entire
chamber was full of the creatures all
standing and watching the researchers
undertook these experiments knowing that
they didn't often turn out well for the
d-class so they didn't seem too worried
about this new development that is until
the subject stated that they could see
three more of the creatures and they
weren't in the test chamber they were in
the observation room in fact one of them
was looking right over one of the three
researchers shoulders immediately the
researchers lost composure and began to
panic they were used to putting d-class
in danger that was part of the job but
they weren't prepared for this in just
moments the observation room became a
bloodbath as the three researchers who'd
been designing and Performing all the
experiments were Torn to Pieces by
creatures they couldn't see SCP 178 had
gone from being one of the more innocent
looking anomalies to one of the most
mysterious and deadly the creatures
seemed to be powerful violent and
Incredibly numerous the fact that they
can only be observed through 178
stereoscopic lenses and kill anyone who
even attempts to interact with them
makes them almost impossible to
understand it was always a tragedy when
the foundation lost good researchers but
the work must continue and the
experiments were soon restarted with
increased safety measures of course
those didn't do much good and after
another disastrous experiment that
resulted in the whole sector getting
locked down all research into SCP 178
was placed under increased scrutiny they
needed to find some way of observing the
creatures without the risk of having to
share space with them the proposed
solution was seeing if the SCP 178
glasses were compatible with camera
technology for remote viewing much like
all stereoscopic glasses they found that
looking through only one lens at a time
was ineffective
the solution was relatively simple a
dual lens camera in a roughly similar
configuration to human eyes this however
didn't give them the Comfort or the
answers they hoped for researchers
commented upon finally seeing the
creatures that they were even more
hideous than they'd ever imagined as
they observed a victim interacting with
the creatures via their new camera they
found that as soon as the creatures were
interacted with in any way they would
grow three Long Claws and attack and
they were as fast as they were were
ferocious from the observations there
were only a few things that the
foundation now knew about them for sure
their physical appearance their violent
nature their enhanced physical abilities
and the fact they appear to be pretty
much everywhere and who knows how long
they'd been here observing us humans
while we glided by them ignorant to
their presence it's enough to make you
think twice before putting on a pair of
3D glasses again but of course never
putting on the glasses doesn't mean
you're safe just knowing about them puts
you in danger they could be standing
next to you right now looking over your
shoulder as you watch this video just
remember if you want to be safe you
can't ever let them know you're aware
after all just because you can't see
something doesn't mean it can't hurt Dr
Seymour Tracy is an ordinary American
man he lives in a two-bedroom home with
a white picket fence in an ordinary sub
urban town in the midwest he gets up
every day and goes to work then in the
evening he comes home to spend time with
his family from the outside Seymour and
his family couldn't be more normal but
in reality there's something very
abnormal about him his life and the
neighborhood where he lives Seymour
Tracy isn't just some office worker he's
a researcher employed by the SCP
Foundation just like all of his
neighbors because this isn't an ordinary
neighborhood it's a functioning sight
satellite facility bought and maintained
by the foundation for the sole purpose
of containing and monitoring a single
SCP SCP 382 SCP 382 is an ordinary
Treehouse 2 m x 2 m in size and built
from ordinary Cherrywood planks and it's
located in one of the trees in the
neighborhood park you might expect that
an anomaly that requires an entire
suburb of people to monitor it is
exceptional Ally difficult to contain
but the truth is SCP 382 is only a uclid
class anomaly fairly tamed by Foundation
standards the fact that the houses
surrounding this SCP are inhabited
solely by Foundation personnel and their
families is more than anything a way to
keep up appearances of this being a
completely normal neighborhood unlike
most Foundation sites the Personnel
working in this unorthodox setup around
SCP 382 are mostly researchers and their
work is just as much anthropological and
diplomatic as it is scientific as you
might have guessed SCP 382 isn't a
normal treehouse on the inside open up
the small hatch in the wall and step
through and you'll find yourself in a
much larger grander tree house that
rests on the upper branches of an
absolutely massive conifer-like tree of
an unidentified species the tree
designated as SCP
3821 is an incredible 160 km tall and
while its own species is not known it
appears to have multiple recognizable
plants grafted onto and growing out of
its bark many of these plants are fruit
bearing and in addition to the
identifiable plants there are also a
number of pitcher plant-like flowers
that collect and hold fresh water these
plants serve as sustenance for the only
known inhabitants of SCP 382 a colony of
around 74 children all between the ages
of 4 and 12 these children live in a
village made up of other tree houses
built among the branches of SCP
382-1908
2's pocket Dimension the children don't
physically age and while Foundation
Personnel can move freely back and forth
through the hatch and SCP 382 all
children under the age of 133 are unable
to cross back through once inside the
pocket Dimension it's a very
extraordinary anomaly but it was up to
the very ordinary Dr Tracy to make
contact with the residents of SCP 382
upon entering he discovered that the
children had formed their own system of
government known as the chief Royal
Council Dr Tracy was introduced to many
of the council's members including
wexley Olen age six a junior council
member Luc Fujimoto age 7 who had taken
the role of city planner and resource
manager Ahmed SED age 11 who served as a
caraker to the younger citizens of SCP
382 and Rachel Jeff age 10 who acted as
a council mediator through interviews
with the subjects Dr Tracy found that
all 74 of the children reported they had
woken up on the porch of a treehouse
after running away from troubled homes
most of the council members had
disappeared in
1996 except for Olen who disappeared in
2005 older residents reported that some
of the Treehouse that make up what is
now their Village were already there
upon their discovery of the pocket
Dimension also pre-existing within the
pocket Dimension was the original leader
of the chief Royal Council a 12-year-old
girl from Ohio named Arya Morrison the
foundation was eager to speak to
Morrison as she was seemingly the first
child to discover SCP 382 but when Dr
Tracy asked the other children where she
was they told him that they didn't know
according to SED and Jeff Morrison
abandoned The Colony 5 months before the
foundation's arrival it was unclear
where she could have gone as drone
exploration conducted by the foundation
revealed that SCP
3821 was the only large living thing for
Miles within the pocket Dimension while
the tree was thriving the surrounding
area was mostly flat decaying and Barren
further research into Morrison's history
showed that her younger sister jacn
Morrison had also gone missing on the
same night but there was no evidence
that jacine had ever entered SCP 382 the
foundation conducted their Research into
the biology of SCP
3821 while maintaining diplomatic
relations with the pocket Dimension
citizens taking advantage of the fact
that adults could move freely in and out
of the hatch the foundation started
working with the chief Royal Council to
improve the weight limits on the village
systems of rope ridges as well as
providing any supp supplies that the
children might need such as additional
food clothing and medical equipment
these Liaisons were extremely helpful
for the children many of whom had been
without adult supervision or care for
over a decade SED for one example had
fallen off of a bridge and broken his
leg several years earlier and had been
living with the pain caused from the
bone being incorrectly set ever since
however there was an unexpected side
effect of this continued contact while
the foundation tried to remain neutral
in their involvement in the policies of
3082 through Dr Tracy's interviews he
discovered that the SCP foundation's
presence in the treehouse had caused a
Schism within the chief Royal Council
the vast majority of the children
including s Jeff and Fujimoto supported
the foundation's presence and wanted to
work with them to find a way to leave
the world of 382 and return back to what
the children called the real world but a
splinter group had developed calling
themselves the neverland movement the
neverland movement were angry Ed by the
foundation's interference and intended
to resist any attempt to return the
children to civilization Olsen had
become the defao leader of the Splinter
Group and made no secrets about his
views on the foundation he swore at
Tracy during interviews and frequently
buted heads with the rest of the council
Fujimoto in particular at one point
Tracy overheard the two of them fighting
with Olen arguing that Neverland gives
them everything they need without any
grown-ups to tell them what to do and
that they would be stupid to give that
up to which Fujimoto responded I was
here back when we were still building
the village I was here before we had
safety nets ladders and fences and
before we figured out how to build a
treehouse that wouldn't fall apart if
someone leaned on a bad wall I was here
before we knew where there was more food
if we needed it when did you get here
huh after we knew what we were doing
listening to the conversation Dr Tracy
heard the children refer again to Arya
Morrison in a way that suggested that
she had some kind of control over the
environment in reference to the incident
where s had broken his leg Fujimoto said
Mary didn't fix his leg right and this
place didn't fix it either Arya prayed
and you know what happened nothing from
this comment the foundation started to
theorize that Arya had somehow been
involved in the creation of SCP 382 and
Ario was officially designated as SCP
382 D2 one morning when Dr Tracy entered
the Treehouse and walked through the
hatch to conduct further interviews he
was greeted by Olen who was the only
child in the main tree house at the time
Tracy asked what was wrong and olssen
explained that the tree had started to
change a wooden slide had appeared
between two of the trees fruit bearing
branches snapping the rope rdge and
making the fruit more difficult to
access on top of that Olson said that
the apples the trees produced were
different now they looked like apples
from the outside but now seemed to be
made of cotton candy on the inside Dr
Tracy put in a request for non-
perishable food moods to be sent through
into the pocket Dimension fearing that
further changes to the tree structure
would mean the children would be
deprived of enough proper nutrition to
survive given these changes it became
apparent that more had to be done to
understand the trees physiology an
exploratory drone was sent into the
dimension with cameras and sensors
collecting data on the lower parts of
the tree that the children hadn't
colonized the Expedition continued as
normal until the Drone operator spotted
a hollow in the tree that had not yet
been documented the cameras detected
movement inside the hollow and on closer
inspection The Operators were shocked to
find it was a person more specifically
it was Arya Morrison the cameras were
only just able to confirm her identity
though as the Drone was knocked out of
the sky by a falling watermelon and the
feed was cut before the request for a
replacement drone could even be approved
though the broken drone started
transmitting again in front of the
camera was Morrison clutching a roll of
duct tape she explained to the camera
that she'd rewired the Drone to resume
the camera feed and remove some of the
drone's fan blades using a system where
the operators of the Drone would rotate
the remaining blades once for yes and
twice for no the foundation was able to
hold a conversation with Morrison she
confirmed much of the information that
the foundation already had on her that
she was from Ohio and that she and her
sister jacn had disappeared in
1996 during the conversation Morrison
wrote down a morr Cod like system
through which to communicate more
complex questions and answers and with
the help of this Morrison code the
foundation was able to conduct a series
of more in-depth interviews with the
subject the first interview occurred 44
hours after first making contact and the
Drone operators explained to her the
nature of the SCP Foundation in basic
terms they assured her that the other
children were still safe in the village
but Morrison didn't volunteer any more
information about herself 9 days later
though she finally told the foundation
her story Arya and Jaclyn Morrison had a
difficult childhood together their
parents fought constantly and would
often leave their sisters at home
without supervision for long periods of
time Jacqueline perhaps aided by all the
time she spent alone displayed an
extremely active imagination so active
in fact that Arya claimed she was able
to pull things out of thin air warping
reality around her to fit her imagined
scenarios Arya recalled that one year
when the Morrison parents had forgotten
Jaclyn's birthday Arya tried to comfort
her by saying that the family had been
planning a surprise party for Jaclyn's
half birthday instead she forgot all
about the white lie until 6 months later
when the girl's parents took them to the
park and everything ARA had told Jaclyn
would be at her half birthday was there
waiting for them knowing the potential
consequences of letting Jaclyn's power
go unchecked Arya always made sure to
remind her sister to turn things back to
normal after they played pretend
together one night in 1996 while their
parents were having a particularly bad
fight the sisters packed a bag and ran
off into the woods after about half an
hour they got turned around but they
kept walking just as afraid of what
would happen to them if they went back
home as they were of being lost in the
woods Arya lost track of jacine for a
moment and suddenly found herself
standing on the porch of SCP 382 unable
to find Jaclyn anywhere Arya searched
the treehouse and in the process became
trapped in SCP 382 pocket Dimension The
Treehouse inside the pocket Dimension
appeared exactly as it does now but the
rest of the tree was devoid of Life
scared alone and running out of water
Arya sat in the treehouse and pretending
that her sister was with her started
telling a bedtime story about fruit
trees and pictures of fresh water the
next day she awoke to find a system of
rope ridges and a Grove where SCP
fruit bearing trees and piter plants had
sprouted overnight Arya found that when
it was in a giving mood the tree would
respond to any requests she made more
children started to appear over time and
they started making additions to the
village with the trees help they would
get what they needed to survive but the
tree refused to let them go in Arya
Morrison's own words jacine likes it too
much here in Neverland I think Jackie
might listen better if I get closer to
the part of her that remembers but for
now she doesn't hear me when I say it's
time to go home trees don't really think
like people do and so the children
continue to live in the world of SCP 382
to this day as a whole town of SCP
Foundation Personnel work to bring them
back and hopefully if they are able to
return to the real world they'll find
it's the world they deserve you hear
their footsteps coming down the halls or
are those your own can you even tell the
difference you can tell they're getting
closer and you can feel the hate the
rage you turn shaking and finally see
them standing right in front of you but
in that moment you might as well be
looking into a mirror and who knows
perhaps you are you just don't seem to
remember having so many Reflections have
you ever heard the saying you are Your
Own Worst Enemy of course it isn't
usually meant literally but what if it
was what if you had to fight a monster
that was you all your flaws are
reflected back at you your strengths
your weaknesses your deepest fears with
no way to escape except a battle to the
death either way you're not making it
out alive it's just a matter of which
version of you survives but this isn't a
thought experiment no according to the
findings of the SCP Foundation it's very
much a reality there is a place where
this nightmare comes to life and it's
known as SCP
1919 scp1 1919 is a hotel and converted
Mansion built in the early 20th century
from the outside it looks pretty much
like it did when it was first built and
it almost looks like a comfortable place
to stay if you ignore the Eastern side
of the building that has sunk partially
into the ground the inside however is a
different story where it's clear the
ravages of time have taken their toll
the floorboards and ceilings are rotting
collapsing in on themselves and the
rooms are filled with debris it's deadly
enough to explore the hotel for these
reasons alone but this is only the
beginning of the danger for person
inside in order to determine just how
dangerous it is for either one person or
group to enter the structure the SCP
Foundation planned a series of research
Expeditions into the abandoned building
led by Foundation scientist Dr lenowitz
the first expedition seemed relatively
normal at least it did at the start a
39-year-old Caucasian d-class maale
known as D7 was sent into the structure
with a camera and a communication system
guided remotely by Dr limet or Dr L and
another operative a former head of the
MTF tow 11 youth hostiles who is
referred to in this file only as t11
when he arrived at the building D7 was
unable to get inside through the front
door or Windows after several minutes of
trial and error he was finally able to
get in through the Western entrance Dr L
picked up a stranged high-pitched
Whistling noise upon d7s entrance into
the building but it quickly faded away
and was disregarded by t11 D7 discovered
a torn painting a portrait of a young
woman with red hair next to the portrait
shallow scratches could be seen in the
wall the floor and parts of the ceiling
suddenly D7 ducked into a hiding place
alarmed he and the other two operatives
listening to his audio feed could hear
heavy breathing and it didn't belong to
D7 Dr Al recommended that D7 evacuate
the building at this sign of another
entity inside but t11 overruled ordering
him to disregard that instruction and
continue his investigation D7 was told
to stay at a safe distance from whatever
was inside with him and attempt to
capture it on video D7 turned off his
flashlight in order to better hide but
t11 commanded that he turn it back on
whatever was caught in the beam of light
was difficult for the camera to see but
it threw D7 into a panic and he began to
run in the opposite direction when
prompted to explain what he saw D7
simply said it was me D7 ran through the
dark panting with fear and exertion
unable to see where his feet were
Landing he tripped over something and
came crashing onto the ground dropping
the video camera this allowed the
observing officers to finally see what
D7 was so frightened by and it became
clear just why D7 was so terrified a man
identical looking to D7 approached from
the end of the hallway making its way
towards the real D7 it was followed by
another man who also resembled D7 and
another all running toward the original
they all looked exactly like him with a
few notable differences they were
dressed in the same uniform with the
same build and the same features but
each had something slightly off about
him one was missing eyelids another had
malformed hands and the third had its
lips fused together into a fleshy mask
beneath its nose Dr L moved to cut the
camera feed but t11 demanded that it be
kept running D7 couldn't be seen by the
camera but the microphone picked up the
sounds of Flesh and cloth being torn
along with pained Panic screams as the
duplicat set upon him after a moment the
screaming stopped 2 hours later the
camera was broken and the Expedition
brought to a troubling end this was the
foundation's first Glimpse at the
creatures inside of SCP 1919 and it was
not pretty it did however allow them to
begin understanding the nature of the
building and what happens when a person
goes inside it appears that when a human
enters the hotel several humanoid
creatures manifest throughout the
building these creatures look like the
subject and are equipped with the same
clothing or items that the subject
brought inside with them though they are
nearly mirror images of the subject they
are always slightly wared in a variety
of ways these have included changes to
Limb and digit length joint Mobility
sealed nostrils lengthened Jaws hanging
loose and Limp missing eyelids and lips
that are fused together these creatures
are highly aggressive towards the
structure of the building itself as well
as to the subject that they resemble
they do not however attack each other
they appear to operate with a hive mind
exhibiting swarm intelligence like that
of an ant colony once they have been
spawned by the entrance of a new person
they will not stop until said person
either escapes the building or is killed
after the unfor forunate end to the
Expedition the foundation prepped for a
second trip inside this time three men
were sent in with Dr L's guidance known
as D3 D4 and D9 video cameras were sewn
into their clothes to leave their hands
free and help avoid some of the issues
that came up during the first expedition
this small team was sent in with the
orders to terminate the remaining copies
of D7 and further examine the hotel's
interior upon opening the door to the
building they were immediately attacked
by one of d 7's copies which D9 was able
to quickly dispatch by firing his weapon
at its head next after a great deal of
reluctance the three men entered the
building where they spotted something
unusual inside Dr Al was horrified when
the camera feed revealed 17 discarded
video cameras spread across the floor
they didn't have much time to react to
this new discovery however because two
doubles one mirroring D7 and another
mirroring D9 emerged from the wall and
began to attack Dr Al ordered the team
to take shelter then called the team of
guards outside of the hotel's perimeter
they were ordered to begin an immediate
full perimeter lock down preventing the
doubles from leaving the hotel D3 D4 and
D9 attempted to make their way to a safe
corner of the building but found
themselves met with a murderous double
at every turn at this point Dr Al began
to hear an unusual sound over the
microphone feed a high-pitch whine like
that of a dentist drill the operatives
on the ground couldn't hear a thing but
on Dr L's end it was deafening as the
team proceeded deeper into the hotel
they became overcome with a strange
feeling of for boing Dr L ordered them
to turn on their flashlights but they
refused and begged Dr L to keep quiet
when prompted to explain D9 said she can
hear you the operative stopped
responding but their camera feeds caught
a faint glowing white light coming from
beneath the door the door opened and the
light flooded the camera making the
images it captured hard to decipher just
a few frames of a quick moving female
silhouette were captured before the
cameras cut to static the bodies of D3
D4 and D9 were never recovered nor were
their cameras a third expedition was
also sent into SCP 1919 but very little
is known about what occurred during it
the video transcript is highly
classified and only those present for
its events or proed to research scp1
1919 have access to it an update to the
SCP 19 199 file following Expedition 3
though indicates that new information
was revealed about the hotel during the
Excursion according to the file update
there is some kind of being at the
center of the location which is causing
all of the other creatures the doubles
to appear the only information available
about this being is the use of the word
her in the official Foundation log about
SCP 1919 this seems to match up with the
last moments of the operatives in
Expedition too when they told Dr L that
she can hear you and the few frames of a
female figure that were captured by
their cameras nothing else is known that
has been made available to anyone
outside a very select few only the
original report exists and all other
copies of it have been destroyed the
foundation has undertaken special
containment procedures to make sure that
none of the entities from inside the
hotel Escape whether they are the evil
twins spawned by humans entering the
building or the mysterious female being
at the center of the entire disturbing
phenomenon the foundation has classified
SCP 1919 as uid and a 2 km radius must
be maintained around SCP 1919 with all
roads leading to the building are
blocked or diverted so that no vehicles
are able to reach it this perimeter is
guarded by a set of at least 40 armed
and armored guards at any given time as
it has been determined that the doubles
spawn by 1919 are equipped with whatever
the human they are copying has no one is
allowed to enter the hotel with body
armor or weapons of any kind anyone that
approaches the perimeter that is not a
part of an official Expedition team will
be immediately terminated no new
Expedition teams are allowed to enter
the building unless all doubles from the
previous Expedition have been
exterminated in the event that they
cannot be exterminated enough time must
elapse between Expeditions that the
previous doubles have starved to death
though they do not seem to feel hunger
the Devils do need to eat to survive and
will die when left alone for long enough
SCP 1919 has been sealed off from the
rest of the world so that no hapless
civilians can wander inside and find
themselves Torn to Pieces by warped
images of themselves but that Comfort
turns cold when you realize that the SCP
Foundation still does not understand
what causes these doubles to spawn is it
scientific Supernatural or something
else no one can can be certain even more
inexplicable is the entity at the center
of all of this an unknown female
presence capable of wrecking frightening
amounts of Violence by turning victim's
own images against them what is the
purpose of these funh housee mirror
nightmares who is she what is she and
what does she want currently the doubles
have shown no interest in leaving the
hotel except to attack Intruders and
thanks to that fact as well as the
reinforced perimeter outside these
copycats have not appeared outside side
of the building itself but what happens
if they do Escape or if the entity that
controls them decides to make her home
elsewhere there is no telling what could
happen if this dark power is allowed to
move Beyond its current containment are
you prepared to fight a vision of
yourself Twisted almost beyond
recognition lunging after you with wide
bulbous eyes unnaturally long arms and a
distended jaw hanging down below its
neck better hope you never have to to
find out everyone loves a good ghost
story whether you're crowded around a
campfire or watching a YouTube video at
3 a.m. there's something fun and
exciting about imagining haunted places
plagued by strange noises and
apparitions part of what makes it so fun
is the idea that any place can be
haunted especially if terrible things
have happened there that decrepit old
house at the end of your street that
80-year-old movie theater where no one
goes anymore a park where one to many
kids went missing all it takes is a
tragic backstory and a creepy atmosphere
and it's easy to believe that any plays
could be teaming with Restless Spirits
so it stands to reason that a place with
as many unsolved deaths as the SCP
Foundation might have a ghost or two
lurking in the shadows if you've ever
suspected that the SCP Foundation might
be haunted well you'd be right it began
as all good ghost stories do with a
series of frightening unexplained events
some time ago Personnel at SCP
Foundation site 30 began to notice
strange things happening around the
facility obviously at a place like an
SCP Foundation containment site strange
is relative but these events seemed to
have nothing to do with any of the
entities contained at the site there
were unexplained sounds reported in the
private quarters of agents and
researchers ranging from Whispers to
screams from an unseen being Personnel
who approached the d-class block at the
site noticed an immediate drop in
temperature with some employees claiming
that they could even see their own
breath several Personnel reported items
going missing while they were alone in
the room most were small and easily
misplaced objects like pens and
clipboards but one man said his wallet
disappeared which wouldn't be that
strange if it hadn't been securely
inside his lab coat other Personnel
would be innocently washing their hands
only to be horrified by the appearance
of a bloody figure in a d-class jumpsuit
in the mirror staring back at them with
hatred in its eyes there were anomalous
computer server errors the feeling of
being watched or followed by some
menacing invisible force even the sight
of a shadowy silhouette fleeing down
corridors and hiding around corners all
of these occurrences were reported to H
high-ups at the foundation but they were
all dismissed the directorial board of
the site insisted that these accounts
were likely the result of employees
cracking under the immense mental stress
of working under such strenuous
circumstances if left alone they were
certain that the reports would stop but
the reports didn't stop and they soon
found out that this was only the
beginning there was an uptick in
containment breaches following these
initial reports in total 12 different
entities were released from their
containment and the origin of these
breaches could not be identified
thankfully the entities were captured
and returned to their containment
facilities before any casualties could
could result but from there things kept
getting worse over the course of several
months there were six different employee
suicides on site security footage of the
deceased operative shortly before their
death showed them acting deeply troubled
engaging in agitated conversation with
someone not visible to the camera at
first it was posited that whoever was
upsetting the employees was in a blind
spot but it quickly became clear that
the dead employees were being tormented
by something invisible stories of
hauntings were one thing but now with
escaped scps and a notable death count
the directorial board decided to mount
an official investigation into the
Unexplained occurrences it was then that
the spirit was officially acknowledged
identified and reclassified as SCP
4973 SCP 4973 was once a d-class worker
who was used as a guinea pig in 25
different experiments with a variety of
entities on site he was reportedly
exposed to multiple unusual and
dangerous anomalies including SCP 158 a
large mechanical arm capable of
extracting an unidentified substance
from any living test subject before he
was brought on board at SCP Foundation
site 30 he was also known as Gordon
Caracus marovich a man who had been
convicted of murder in the second degree
after stabbing his wife 24 times in the
chest with a kitchen knife during his
incarceration marovich was transferred
to the custody of the SCP foundation and
placed at site 30 where he was given a
new name
d1000 during an experiment involving a
redacted entity d1000 was killed and his
remains were disposed of at a nearby
waste Refinery it was then only 3 months
after his death that the initial reports
of ghost activity began SCP 4973 is
regarded as a class 4 spectral entity
meaning that it is an entity displaying
a high degree of aggression and
malevolence towards a specific spe ific
individual or group in this case the
spirit displays hostility towards a very
specific group The SCP Foundation class
4 entities can affect the environment
around them move objects reduce the
temperature in a room and induce
hallucinations and humans that it comes
into contact with these hallucinations
are thought to be the cause of the
increase in employee suicides that
occurred after 4973 is first appearance
one of the many ways in which SCP 4973
acted out and what is believed to be an
attempt at revenge on the foundation as
a whole was to somehow gain access to
the skip net database terminal this
allowed the spirit to learn about the
entities contained at the site as well
as personal details regarding the lives
of research security and administrative
staff working there this information is
likely what allowed 4973 to cause
several suspected containment breaches
though the specifics of those breaches
have been expunged from official records
40 973 was eventually contained within
an apparatus known as The incorporeal
Entity vacuum chamber which is
constantly monitored by a team of
Specialists with an MTF mu13
affectionately nicknamed Ghostbusters in
order to prevent it from escaping four
Harrington Hollow neutralizer Wards have
been placed at the door to the
containment facility this containment
method has been largely effective though
the spirit had escaped a handful of
times and had to be recaptured and
placed back into the ievc in order to
understand as CP
4973 and how it was able to access the
database Dr lorine Casper was assigned
to conduct an interview with the spirit
speaking to it as it was in containment
and a transcript of this interview was
available in the official Foundation
archives Dr Casper began the
conversation politely addressing the SCP
as Gordon and asking him how he was
Gordon refused to comply with the round
of questioning going as far as to yell
at Dr Casper until she reminded him that
he faced the risk of termination if he
refused to answer her questions Dr
Casper pointed out that the files
accessed by 4973 required clearance that
the spirit would have no way of
possessing he responded that he simply
waved his hand across the terminal in
order to access it explaining it freaked
out for a second then just stop I could
just move my fingers around the air and
the tabs would just roll up easy as that
Dr Casper asked for clarification
inquiring how he could even do something
something like that 4973 continued his
explanation beats me it felt like some
attraction like magnets from AAR getting
closer and closer I don't know something
like that finding this answer
unsatisfactory Dr Casper pushed further
asking for an explanation of SCP
4973 attempts to release dangerous
on-site anomalies from containment this
question seemed to stump him and he
claimed not to understand what Dr Casper
meant she explained that the ID cards of
Dr yurov and Dr Orson were used to open
the facilities from which these
anomalies escaped 4973 was shocked that
he had even been suspected of this
attack and insisted not to know who
Orson or yurkov even were all of a
sudden he trailed off there was silence
for a moment and Dr Casper began to
collect her notes and leave assuming
that the interview was over much to her
surprise SCP 4973 began to laugh a loud
aborus laugh of complete and utter
Delight Casper asked what 4973 was
laughing about and was met with the
response God this whole time you and
your ghost hunting crew never knew he
refused to clarify what it was the
doctor and her crew had missed only
saying God that look on your face when
you find out it's been right under your
nose this whole time he continued to
laugh at Dr Casper for the remainder of
the interview refusing to answer any
further questions or explain any of his
comments finally Dr Casper grew
exasperated and laughed ending the
interview for real this time following
this perplexing interview Dr Casper
inexplicably abandoned her post at site
30 her supervisors could not reach her
neither could any of the other
researchers at the site no one had heard
from her for an entire week until one
day she called director Eric Riverson of
site3 on his personal phone line he
recorded the conversation and a
transcript has been included in the file
for SCP 4973 Dr Casper explained to
director Riverson that she had been
hiding in her private residence away
from the site and that she no longer
considered any part of the site safe in
fact she suggested that all SCP
Foundation sites might be potentially
compromised she explained her
conversation with SCP
4973 and the questions it provoked her
to ask if he had not been behind the
containment breaches then who was he
never encountered Dr yurov or Orson in
any of the tests administered on him and
Orson wasn't even employed at the
foundation until after 4973 his death Dr
Casper posited that though the spirit of
Gordon was not responsible for the
breaches another spectral force or
forces at the site might be her
hypothesis that site 30 was positively
infested with the vengeful spirits of
Class D employees lost over the years
during various experiments in order to
prove her Theory Dr Casper got her hands
on all the experimental equipment used
by the Department researching spectral
anomalies the general consensus among
researchers in this field is that
Spirits leak out a kind of energy known
as ectoplasm wherever they go it has
been compared to the skin Left Behind
when a spider or a snake molds a
non-essential portion of the entity that
is shed and leaves a residue in areas
where they have been unsurprisingly a
huge amount of ectoplasm was detected
inside of site 30 the spirits were
undetected at first as many of them were
d dorant for quite some time dormant
Spirits are spirits that are not aware
of their surroundings or the
circumstances of their deaths and they
do not emit large quantities of
ectoplasm it is likely that after Gordon
was trapped several of the dormant
spirits of site 30 began to remember
what was done to them and manifest in
more aggressive ways because Gordon was
presumed to be the only Spirit at the
site their gradual appearance and acting
out was either ignored or presumed to be
Gordon escaping from containment after
her realization Dr Casper identified an
additional five active Spirits at the
site and was able to capture and contain
one of them Dr Casper warned director
rierson that there were likely far more
Spirits than just those five and it was
only a matter of time before they woke
up and became active like the others the
large amount of previous containment
breaches attributed to simple human
error becomes deeply Sinister once it is
clear that there have been vengeful
Spirits hiding in plain sight the entire
time as Gordon put it in his interview
they were just under their noses the
whole time Dr Casper's findings and the
story of site 30 present a troubling
possibility every SCP Foundation site
has used massive amounts of Class D
Personnel in human experiments with
dangerous entities and the body count at
nearly all of them is staggering if Dr
Casper is right then every single site
has the makings of a haunted house all
of them could be infested with the
spirits of dead angry declass who are
just waiting to wake up and take their
revenge on the still living members of
the organization that killed them and
it's only a matter of time before they
get the chance you've just had a night
of your life in beautiful Las Vegas
Nevada you spend hours shooting crabs
dancing in clubs and eating more than
your Phill at the famous all you can eat
buffets you're staggering back to your
hotel room high on life in the early
hours of the the morning when you notice
something strange a long dark tunnel
just off the side of the strip you
didn't notice it on the way in perhaps
because you were distracted by all the
glitz Glamour and hypnotic Casino lights
you see the tunnel and your
overstimulated mind feels drawn to it
you stumble in and start walking during
your walk you can feel your bones
cracking they don't shatter like you've
just been hit by a train they shift you
feel the entire shape of you bending
into something different but it doesn't
stop with your skeleton your organs
start to feel strange and then your skin
in the complete darkness of the tunnel
you have no idea what's going on so you
just keep walking eventually you find
your way into a lush green forest it's
beautiful but it feels like it should be
a million miles away from the Arid
desert of NADA you were only in the
tunnel for a few minutes what gives
hello you call out is that is anybody
there no answer you explore further into
this empty Forest its trees are far as
the eye can see but no animals that's
when you see something that catches your
eye a puddle of crystal clear water but
it's not the puddle itself that draws
your attention it's what reflects back
at you when you stare into it at first
you can hardly believe it but as you
move your mouth in shock and the
reflection moves its mouth too it's
suddenly all too real you've been turned
into a fox an orange bushy tailed fox
you scream and bolt all the way back to
the tunnel that led you here you sprint
through and feel your entire body
changing once more when you finally hit
the wall of dry Vegas heat on the other
side you're human again you breathe a
sigh of relief and stumble back to your
hotel room the next day you only vaguely
remember what happened and because
you're not crazy you assume it was just
all a wild dream what you just
encountered is a uclid class SCP known
as SCP
2746 a seemingly innocent tunnel near
the Vegas Strip which holds a portal to
a Fantastical World designated by the
foundation as SCP
2746-20
tunnel and began sending their field
agents and researchers on fact finding
Expeditions inside the place was already
a ghost town a forested land mass
approximately 111 km in diameter with no
notable Signs of Life the foundation
discovered that this place had a strange
effect on people and animals who came in
from our world humans who entered
assumed the form of a random animal but
retained their intelligence and vocal
cords creating talking animals animals
brought into
27461 retained their animalistic
intelligence but grew human-like vocal
cords allowing them to repeat simple
phrases before the mass Exodus or
Extinction event that left
27461 Baron the foundation figured out
that this place was populated by a whole
civilization of intelligent animals like
something out of a fairy tale these
animals through a mix of brains and
Magic were able to leave written records
and create impressive architecture like
homes and places of worship Foundation
researchers became fascinated with how
exactly this Society operated and what
could have led to its sudden downfall
all thanks to a mix of advanced
archaeology and Records left behind by
the creatures this is what the
foundation determined the society these
talking intelligent animals lived in was
a kind of religious oligarchy meaning
power was Consolidated by the few in the
top social class Society was divided
into three segments Crafters Scholars
and honorables with the Crafters being
the most powerful members of society and
honorables being the least powerful the
state sponsored churches acted in
worship of a being simply called the
maker who fills a similar role to the
abrahamic god the Crafters whose number
total 13 were believed to be immortal
and were responsible for building the
majority of the culture and architecture
found in 27
46-1 the scholars acted as their wise
assistants and the honorables were a
mixed class of artists carpenters and
Artisans it seemed that this culture had
a pretty good thing going no system of
currency was ever invented and the
economy operated on a barter system the
foundation believes that initially the
citizens of this world didn't need to
eat to survive and so only needed to
barter for material Goods though it's
worth noting that the conditions of
immortality only apply to natives of
this region people born on Earth but
assuming animal forms while entering
27461 still need nutrition to survive
however a great tragedy soon caused a
fundamental shift in the balance of life
life and Society within
27461 the maker decided it wanted to
test or punish its subjects with two
major changes first humans would be
forbidden from entering the domain and
second the maker now made the
consumption of food necessary for
continued survival and Sanity nothing
was ever the same because nobody had
needed to eat prior to this food stores
had never been made and the inhabitants
had no agricultural knowledge that would
allow them to easily mass produced more
as a result while the crafters and
Scholars were able to feed on fruits
from luxurious private Gardens the
honorables were forced to resort to
eating each other or other inhabitants
of
27461 this began a bloody Rift that
split Society from the top down one half
led by the powerful Crafters sari and
suard wanted to preserve society as it
was and continued to worship the maker
sari took the form of a Flemish giant
rabbit and Seward appeared as a houseat
the opposition led by former Crafters
Frederick and agathos with The Reluctant
help of a scholar named Clovis wanted to
get revenge on the maker for all he'
done and kill him completely altering
Society don't be fooled by their
appearances though many of the
inhabitants of
27461 were fiercely intelligent
Sorcerers and the apocalyptic Civil War
they sparked came to be known to the
foundation as event nahash like many
wars there would be no real winners here
only survivors and even then not for
long it was a bloody and horrific War
all attempts at finding a diplomatic
solution failed Frederick and agathos
would not stop until they had the
maker's blood on their paws in the end
though they were defeated and for their
traitorous crimes they were to be
punished by SAR and Seward in horrific
ways to make examples of them since
neither could die
they were given Fates worse than death
instead Frederick was up first before
the war he'd been a leader prized for
his courage and Ingenuity he created
something known as the great fire which
provided the kingdom with light for his
so-called atrocities against the maker
he was given the punishment of permanent
crucifixion and relocation to a place
known as the under plane his snout was
cut off his face and he was set
permanently Ablaze in a manner that
would leave him forever suffering and
would make him appear to look like a
monster to all next went agathos she was
Frederick's sister and was seen as The
Mastermind of many of their schemes she
would be forever encased in white clay
and bled through her eyes until the sin
drains from her she's now a living
crying statue existing in a state of
permanent imprisonment for her part in
the crimes against the maker Clovis
because her involvement in the coupe was
unwilling was given a more minor
punishment one of her eyes was removed
and she was permanently placed in a
broken human body effectively banishing
her from her home in
27461 forever though they may have won
things didn't end much better for SAR
and SRA the Civil War had fractured
their world and in the aftermath the
survivors chose to leave in hopes of
finding a better life elsewhere Zari and
SEO though felt partially responsible
for everything that had happened and so
they decided to remain in their Dying
World before they themselves died or
perhaps moved on to different forms
leaving their animal bodies behind they
left a final note it was from this note
that the foundation learned much of the
story of SCP
2746 this may seem like a pretty open
and shut case another magical realm
destroyed by tragedy in Civil War much
like the land of fantasy and SCP
1762 but what's really bizarre here is
that this is only the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the stories of some of
these key figures in the event nahash
first what became of the two Rebels
agathos and Frederick today they're two
parts of the feared and deadly SCP 1913
Frederick now going by Freddy is a
nightmarish faceless fire demon in the
form of a dog slavishly devoted to the
protection of his sister agathos now
known as Agatha still trapped in white
clay
her leaking blood now deadly to the
touch Clovis is still believed to be in
League with agathos and Frederick and
may now be related to the Sinister SCP
1903 a oneeyed rabbit-like human but
strangest of all is the possible truth
behind SAR and sear the two devotees to
the maker who remained in
2746-20 Infamous Las Vegas Branch they
took on these more animalistic forms
after their deaths sari may have once
been agent saraki a Japanese American
woman who died in the line of duty in
1960 Seward was once Dr Stuart Hayward
Cy's partner his new name acting as a
kind of fusion of the first and last
name he had in life this is only the
beginning of the animal themed weirdness
occurring around site 45 the
foundation's Vegas Branch but this
series of anomalies collected under the
term pitch Haven we'll have to wait for
another video after all you know what
they say what happens in Vegas stays in
Vegas from far away in orbits around the
earth the nuclear Holocaust almost
looked beautiful bright white pin Pricks
dotting the planet's surface glinted up
at the escaping jet for Generations much
of humanity had lived in fear that the
destruction of the world would come from
countries launching nuclear weapons at
each other
no one expected it to come when they
started launching them against
themselves the invasion of the weasels
had been as Savage as it was Swift much
of the human population had been wiped
out before any military forces had
mobilized in any significant fashion no
one was sure if the launching of the
nuclear weapons was intentional or
accidental but as soon as one country
fired the others quickly followed suit
Earth's rich and Powerful the 1% of the
1% stared in silence as their home was
ripped apart the High Altitude jet
carrying them steadily descended back
down to earth in the direction of the
Antarctic 500 people in total chosen as
the successors of the human race
shuffled off the Jet and threw the
Frozen Outpost an alarm blared wrenching
all of them out of their shellshocked
silence a second later the station shook
violently they had been found there was
no time left they needed to leave right
now the swarm of people stampeded
through the Outpost throwing one another
out of the way in a desperate attempt to
save their own lives to save the lives
of the human race in front of them the
portal stood open the Green Pastures
beautiful trees it all felt so offensive
as the Earth behind them was engulfed in
war all those countless beautiful spaces
were torn apart and left to waste but
they couldn't think about it now they
had to make it through the handful of
the survivors of the human race ran
through the open portal just as an
explosion ripped apart the remaining
Outpost SCP 001 yellow refers to a base
of operation used for a foundation
continuance protocol specifically
project yellow in the event of a world
destroying catastrophe where Humanity
appears irrevocably doomed there is one
Bastion of Hope referred to as the
Garden of Eden by some of the crew
yellow contains a large circular Central
space complete with lush green grass and
an orchard measuring 500x 500 M this
open space constitutes the main living
area of project yellow surrounding the
space are tall sheer Cliffs too vertical
to be climbed uned built into these
Cliffs are 500 sleeper Chambers in which
those evacuated from planet Earth will
be suspended in cryosleep until a time
when Earth is fit to be repopulated or a
new home has been discovered how can the
foundation guarantee that this Safe
Haven avoids the calamities that could
befall planet Earth by housing project
yellow in a separate Dimension a pocket
Dimension to be specific following the
successes of project bifrost in which
SCP 2591 omega's ability to access
fictional pocket Dimensions was utilized
the foundation was able to establish a
relatively stable and reliable dimension
for yellow to occupy the only way to
access the base of operations was via a
dimensional Rift or portal house deep in
the Antarctic now of course if yellow's
population consisted of 500 people in
cryosleep cut off from planet Earth
there would be no one capable of
conducting maintenance or assessing the
possibility of returning to planet Earth
therefore carved into the cliffs
alongside the sleeper cells were living
quarters for the crew of 60 Specialists
it was this Workforce who sat down
together on the night of the apocalypse
and raised a toast in a more Bittersweet
celebration all 500 of the evacuees had
managed to make it safely through the
portal before its collapse each of them
had been welcomed to project yellow and
shown to their individual sleeper pods
before being entered into cryosleep for
the foreseeable future but as each of
the crew members raised their glasses
into the air Dr Katrina Keys couldn't
help but feel uneasy about the
proceedings working in this job you'd
have to have a dark sense of humor and
an ability to move past things that
could destroy the mental well-being of
your average person even then she
struggled to come to terms with the near
destruction of the human race for her
and the rest of the crew life would look
nothing like it did before they arrived
here it was vital for the Integrity of
the project that the crew remained
consistent and effective in their work
indefinitely as a result yellow had been
set up with perpetuity in mind every 55
years she and all of her crewm mates
would pass on their knowledge memories
and entire sense of being into a genetic
clone they would then die allowing their
clone to take over the responsibility of
those tasks in another 55 years this
would repeat again and again and again
all this time it is the crew's
responsibility to monitor the status of
Earth through the use of 100 drones once
the Earth is deemed safe all 500
sleepers may be awoken and briefed on
the current situation if all 500
unanimously vote that returning to Earth
is safe they will do so otherwise they
will return to cryosleep and the process
will continue it was little wonder that
Dr Keys was unable to raise a glass with
her colleagues at the prospect of being
stuck here cloned in indefinitely for
Generations she sat in silence as they
raised their glasses and then emptied
them a couple of them coughed and
sputtered their drinks must have gone
down the wrong way but then more coughs
filled the room along with choking
sounds much to Dr Keys's horror within
less than a minute she found herself
alone surrounded by the 59 corpses of
her crew mates in order for project
yellow to be viable indefinitely it was
Paramount that they find a solution for
natural wear and tear
through generation after generation of
usage essential items such as tools
computer systems and even articles of
clothing would eventually wear away and
fall into disrepair as such project
yellow was set up as a selective entropy
Zone in which inorganic matter would not
degrade over time achieving such a Zone
was naturally an incredibly difficult
undertaking project bifrost underwent
countless iterations as the team strive
to create a stable and balanced
fictional pocket Dimension capable of
sustaining human life long term over the
next few days after the death of her
crew mates Dr Katrina Keys read through
as much as she could about project
bifrost in the notes she found records
of Dimensions where lava rained from the
sky and the grass was radioactive yellow
had been the First Dimension without any
glaringly obvious hazards for human life
but naturally their work had quirks one
key Quirk was that the chemical
composition of Cyanide and their drinks
had been switched with one another the
only crew member not to raise a toast
had been the only crew member not to
drink a glass full of poison months went
by leaving Dr Keys alone to assess her
situation the drones strategically
positioned all around Earth to monitor
its safety levels had been
systematically destroyed by the weasels
only one feed remained a security camera
on the other side of the portal and the
Antarctic Outpost there was virtually no
Intel to go off of no way of knowing
what the status of planet Earth was
aside from the fact that this one burnt
out shell of a room still existed some
days Keys would stare at the screen for
hours forgetting to go to bed on others
she would walk through the orchard
trying her best to pretend that nothing
outside of this 500x 500 met space
existed in away it didn't the orchard of
yellow did not consist of your usual
apple trees instead suspended from
branches were essential supplies that
the crew would need while Manning and
maintaining this base of operations some
trees grew antibiotic drugs others long
strands of linen capable of being
fashioned into clothing Dr Keys's
favorite tree was the one that grew
rolls of toilet paper and tubes of
toothpaste it almost reminded her of a
Halloween prank Dr Keys's mental state
steadily deteriorated as year after year
she walked through the same Orchard
alone never before in history had one
human being had so much control over the
fate of the human race at any moment Dr
Keys could have inputed a few simple
commands hands into the computers and
killed off all 500 of the remaining
human beings in existence the decision
not to to hold on to hope that one day
Humanity will be able to start again was
the only thing that kept her going day
after Lonely Day only that and the other
thing the prospect of having to prepare
for her clone to take over while
constructing the cloning pods the crew
had made a number of small errors the
most glaring of which was that the fact
that while all of the genetic material
would be transferred from one person to
their clone Offspring The mine would not
in other words the Clone that would
replace her in this facility in 55 years
time would be starting out from scratch
as a regular newborn baby no memories no
Advanced cognition so Dr Keys went about
preparing for the next ofkin she herself
would die in the cloning process meaning
that she would need to come up with a
way of raising a child to be capable of
running the whole facility from Beyond
the Grave item one on her to-do list
create a god that her offspring would
forever be in service to with a sardonic
smile Dr Keys came up with an
appropriately amusing name Tracy the
sparkling 70 years later yellow was
still operated by just a single crewmate
only now this crewmate was a 15-year-old
girl nicknaming herself kk2 she went
about all of her daily tasks with
infectious excitement the idea that she
alone was responsible for the fate of
the human race could not make her
happier and she was determined not to
screw it up both for her sake and to not
anger her God Tracy the sparkling whom
she worshiped every evening before bed
whenever a problem would come up she
would go and visit kk1 where she knew
she would be met with Sound Advice
pushing open the door to the crew
quarters KK 2 would find the corpse
lying on the floor in its usual place as
a number of pre-recorded messages would
bark at her lesson NE 957 why taking a
bath is important even if no one but you
will ever know how you smell all she had
to do was not anger the disciplinary
drones with their harsh tasers and do
her duty until it was time for kk3 to
take over at that point she' be welcomed
into the Afterlife with all the other
kks a wonderful and magical place known
simply as Burger King that was until kk2
got far enough through the audio
recordings of her predecessor to
discover that Tracy the sparkling was
entirely made up and her life meant
nothing it was just a stepping stone for
another clone for another clone for
another clone until eventually the Earth
would be okay by KK 52 the remaining
camon Earth the one housed in the
Antarctic Outpost went offline while
inorganic material within yellow
compound would not undergo aging the
same could not be said of the circuitry
left on Earth generation after
generation of KK lived and died each one
growing more spiteful towards the one
that came before them each one did their
best to undermine the one that would
come after them the L around Tracy the
sparkling expanded further and further
with each generation there would be
waves of Highly religious kks followed
by waves of devoutly atheistic ones as
each sought to rebel against their
pseudo parents KK 89 was the first to
expand the religious movement to include
the teaspoons very methodically she went
through each teaspoon in the canteen and
named it after a different animal from
Earth before long subsequent kks
established a shrine to the teaspoons
the living space of project yellow
steadily descended into madness with
writings all over the walls bizarre
decorations and rituals long forgotten
until a new KK came along and invented
something to take their place KK 216
lived her entire life in silence never
once recording an audio log or even
talking to herself she lived and died
walking through the Garden in silence
wrapped up in Linens KK 310 did the
opposite she fancied herself a music
composer and scrolled the lyrics to
haunting Symphonies about nuclear
apocalypse Eternal isolation and the
prospect of the Angel of Death coming to
rescue her across all of the walls no
matter how hard any of the kks tried
however none of them were able to hack
into the cloning machine generation
after generation of Dr Keys lived and
died desperate to know what a friend was
to have someone else to talk to but
despite all their best efforts they were
unable to tamper with the cloning
machine to get it to spit out another
person for several hundred years the kks
gave up entirely that was until KK 507
came along day after day she sat at the
cloning machine desperately typing away
at it trying her best to figure out how
the computer coding worked the downside
of living in a pocket Universe was that
none of the computer circuitry behaved
the way it would on Earth she was
certain that she'd made progress any
generation now they were going to have a
breakthrough and be able to make a
friend when all of a sudden a totally
alien noise filled the containment space
the sound that hadn't been heard from
Millennia alert door controls overridden
opening KK 507 turned around in horror
to see that the portal the entrance to
their world from Earth had been opened
the figure of a man no not a man a robot
painted to almost look like a crash test
dummy stepped out into the orchard hello
the goddess has informed us that this is
the last Bastion of the true human race
is that correct KK 507 opened her mouth
and screamed throwing indestructible
lizards into fats of acid hunting
strange chicken men through forests in
Ireland arguing in Latin with a man
wearing a haunted Roman centurion's
helmet when you join the SCP Foundation
you might be expecting high octane drama
off the time especially with the name
street sweepers you'd expect this mobile
task force to be neck deep in some real
action-packed street racing maybe you
wouldn't think that they'd be tasked
with driving all day every every day in
4-Hour shifts tailing a semitruck all
over Birmingham Alabama but as agent
Moore and his colleague pulled into the
layby behind the truck neither of them
were ready for what they were about to
witness SCP 2590 was first discovered by
the foundation at a routine traffic stop
investigating a totally different
anomaly in the Birmingham area agents
Peters and Smith had been posing as
local police officers the foundation had
been trying to track down an Ara fact
that was supposedly being smuggled
across the US in the back of a
non-descript station wagon Peters and
Smith had been allocated a pair of beat
up old police cruisers which they'
parked across the dirt road fully
blocking any traffic from coming through
it was several hours into their shift
when the incident occurred just at the
point they were starting to lose focus
taking a look through the suitcases and
memorabilia from a family's trip to
Disney World Peters had taken way too
long to hear the noise noise of the
engine swelling behind him he spun
around to see the hulking shape of the
semi-truck barreling straight towards
him agent Smith and a family of five
with only 2 seconds to react he yelled
out at the top of his lungs and dived
out of the way leaving the trunk of the
car wide open with five screams emerging
from inside Smith who had been sitting
in one of the Cruisers only just managed
to get out before the semi made contact
eyes closed agent Peters waited for the
inevitable sound of screaming rubber the
bang of metal on metal and the shower of
Glass on asphalt but it never came when
he opened his eyes the station wagon was
still parked up in front of them the two
police cruisers still blocking the road
and all the Disney merch still piled
high in the trunk the semi was driving
off along the road on the other side of
their blockade with not a scratch on it
without a moment's hesitation agent
Smith who had kept his eyes open and
witnessed the whole thing leapt into
action he ordered his partner still
lying confused in the dirt to administer
Class A amnestics to the family and call
in for backup agent Smith himself jammed
his keys into the ignition twisting them
so hard he almost bent the metal and
took off after the vehicle what agent
Smith and Peters had just witnessed was
the very first Foundation exposure to
SCP
2590 fondly nicknamed trailer trash as
Smith pulled up alongside the vehicle
and studied it for the first time he
made a note of its initial appearance
over the radio and appear appearance
which remains unchanged years later the
badges on the vehicle claim that it is
an international proar daycab
semi-trailer truck complete with an
unmarked trailer as the agent flicked on
his lights and indicated that the
vehicle should pull over he noted that
it didn't have any license plates on it
either front or rear he leaned forward
in his seat trying to peer into the cab
to make out the driver but in the
Alabama Sun the man just looked like a
shadowy figure they drove side by side
along along the road for almost a mile
the truck made no signs of pulling over
despite agent Smith's continued
insistence and repeated flashes of the
cop lights but it also didn't attempt to
pull away either it just continued to
drive a few mph below the speed limit
the driver didn't seem to look across at
him once having discussed it with
Foundation staff they decided it was
best not to draw attention to the
situation they had no idea whether this
SCP was hostile or posed any threat to
civilian life but having blue and red
lights flashing at it appeared to be
doing little to change the situation
instead he switched off the sirens and
pulled in behind the truck tailing it
around Birmingham as the foundation Reed
further agents to respond to the
situation for almost an hour nothing of
note happened agent Smith drove behind
the trailer watching it like a hawk he
observed that it obeyed every traffic
law to a te it never broke the speed
limit never cut anyone off and left room
for other V vehicles to merge if it
hadn't seen a drive straight through a
roadblock as if it wasn't there he would
have never suspected a thing but then
the truck turned its turn signal on they
had just come off the highway and merged
onto a quiet side street just as the sun
was starting to hang low in the sky the
truck crept across the side of the road
squeezing its brakes gently and stopped
agent Smith matched the action the whole
way pulling up about 20 ft behind the
trailer in constant radio communication
he kicked open open his door and stepped
out into the evening air Foundation
Personnel advised that he keep his hand
on his gun at all times and approach
with caution he didn't really need them
to tell him that Smith called for the
driver to step out of the cab no
response the truck just sat there with
its hazards on engine off after a moment
there was a clunk and the trailer door
started to slowly open all by itself
agent Smith called in backup but they
were still several minutes out instead
he ran back to the the car gun raised
and waited to see what was inside as the
door slowly opened to reveal nothing no
not quite nothing there was something
small on the floor of the trailer right
in the center as if it hadn't been moved
around at all by the vehicle's motion it
was red a kind of elongated cuboid he
reported it all to the foundation over
his radio then paused when he recognized
what it was a KitKat candy bar or to be
more specific a KitKat chunky what
happened after this point was hazy agent
Smith was found on the roadside just 20
minutes later confused about what had
happened the truck was nowhere in sight
however a security camera from a
convenience store just up the street
happened to capture the interaction in
the footage you see agent Smith
approaching the trailer with his gun
raised looking at the KitKat he tries to
enter the trailer but is unable to so he
approaches the driver's side door while
talking to the shadowy figure in the cab
he drops his gun and stands motionless a
conf confused and sleepy expression on
his face until the trailer door closes
and the SCP drives away contact was
reestablished with SCP 2590 soon after
and has been maintained almost
uninterrupted ever since the findings
made on that initial encounter seem to
hold true across further examination
Personnel have reached out to Navar
International the company that
supposedly manufactures this model of
semitruck but there appears to be no
records of its creation or shipment to
the US in fact no documentation at all
can be attributed to the truck or any
components on it the driver in the front
cab is a humanoid figure who is
perpetually shrouded in Shadow
designated SCP
25901 attempts to reveal the driver's
figures have proved ineffective as even
powerful spotlights do not shed enough
light into the cab to render the driver
visible quite what this driver's role is
in the operation of SCP 2590 is unknown
as SCP 25901 appears to have some
proximity-based amnestic qualities as
anyone approaching it on foot has
reported memory loss and confusion soon
after just like agent Smith as also
discovered by the two agents and their
roadblock containment of this SCP is
simply not possible while the majority
of the time the SCP is corporeal it
possesses the ability to pass through
solid objects at will all attempted
roadblocks have resulted in the same
thing happening the SCP will just phase
right through on them as if nothing was
there since it cannot be contained in
the usual way a different operation has
been set up to monitor the truck's
activities which so far have proven to
be apparently harmless to the civilian
population mobile task force gamma 133
also known as the street sweepers has
been established to follow this SCP
around Birmingham at all times they
operate in 4-Hour shifts with two agents
in unmarked Vehicles sticking close
behind the in the trailer at all times
the foundation was able to fit a
tracking device onto it as well
providing researchers with continuous
location data for where they can find
the vehicle at seemingly random times
supposedly determined by the SCP itself
it pulls over somewhere quiet and opens
the door to its trailer the door will
remain open for 60 seconds and then
close again any attempts to entered the
trailer have been blocked by some kind
of invisible barrier seemingly
impenetrable to approaches more violent
and destructive methods of Entry cannot
be authorized for testing due to the
heavy civilian population in the
surrounding area every time the doors
open there is something different in the
trailer researchers are trying to
ascertain some kind of pattern or
messaging behind most of the objects but
many seem to be random the current list
of things that have appeared in the back
of SCP 2590 include an iPhone 3G a red
apple and a lit light bulb without any
visible form of power supply most
notable about the objects in the trailer
is that often they appear to be human
beings as happened on the night that
agent Moore was on duty in the street
sweepers the agents pulled in behind the
truck as per usual when it slowed to a
stop beside the highway agent Moore got
out of the vehicle second unenthused
about the monotony of the task he had
been assigned expecting to see a
cardboard box or a ChapStick when the
trailer door opened he was left shocked
when he came face to face with him self
few people can say they have seen
themselves in real life most of them
have been administered with various
amnestics to make them forget but agent
Moore went on to report how bizarre of
an experience it was he claimed that it
was utterly unlike looking in a mirror
where your reflection is flipped and
follows your every move seeing yourself
standing in three dimensions moving
independently and evidently in a great
deal of distress is an experience that
few would envy any time a human being
materialized deves in the trailer they
appear to be in a great deal of distress
as they attempt to escape through the
invisible barrier agent Moore and his
partner agent Hall could do nothing but
stand and watch in confusion as the copy
of him attempted to free himself before
after the usual 60 seconds the trailer
door closed and the vehicle pulled away
again several instances have occurred of
duplicate humans appearing in the
trailer but each time the original
person seems to have had no knowledge of
this taking place and nothing out of the
ordinary happens to them however there
appears to be some small pattern
demonstrating the SCP as an awareness of
the foundation as it has also duplicated
agent english's sister who has no
connection to this SCP at all incident
16 was the most distressing of all as a
large slab of metal appeared in the back
of the trailer with the SCP Foundation
logo painted across it agent englas and
schults were on duty at this time and
observed copious amounts of blood
flowing out of the metal slab before
long the blood filled the back of the
trailer pushing up against the invisible
barrier all of a sudden 52 seconds into
the encounter the barrier vanished and a
Cascade of blood with the slab inside
were launched out at the two agents at a
speed of over 190 km an hour killing
them both instantly since this incident
SCP 2590 has been treated with greater
caution the most mysterious thing to
have come from researching this truck
came on December 4th 2011 when for the
first time the truck's tracking Beacon
stopped working it had been seen pulling
into an abandoned warehouse and so a
team of street sweepers was immediately
dispatched to investigate when they
arrived they found the vehicle moving
through the warehouse at a slow crawl
choosing to pursue on foot and leave a
pair of agents at the entrance they
followed the SCP through the facility
until it came to what agents described
as a service tunnel or sewer of some
sort putting headlamps on they followed
the truck down into into the tunnel
maintaining radio contact throughout as
they reported the direction they were
traveling and the distance it quickly
became apparent to Foundation Personnel
that this was no ordinary tunnel the
warehouse was positioned overlooking a
cliff and so the geography was not
physically possible as the street
sweepers descended further into the
tunnel they noted there was increased
levels of carbon monoxide radio contact
started to dip in and out losing signal
as they went further downhill just at
the edge of their signal with the
foundation the truck stopped and opened
its trailer door inside was just a
single piece of parchment with the words
I'm just delivering a message written on
it after the usual 60 seconds the
trailer door closed and the truck
continued after they had passed the
kilometer Mark the radio signal worsened
quickly and after a couple of scrambled
messages the team down there were not
heard from again the channel stayed open
for another 6 hours before the
foundation made the decision to announce
the agents missing in action in March
2015 over 3 years later a radio signal
came into contact with the foundation
again from Burmingham Alabama it was
from the headset of the squad leader who
had gone into the tunnel initially
confused as to who had gained access to
the cons channel the foundation demanded
that the agent State his full name and
rank the agent himself confused obliged
questioning why they were so suspicious
he and his team claimed to have only
lost contact for about 15 minutes they
had followed the FCP a little further
until carbon monoxide levels had risen
too high to continue at which point they
had watched the truck disappearing into
the distance as they walked back to the
surface all agents have undergone
extensive psychological Rehabilitation
to settle them back into society as well
as classes to fill them in on things
like the London Olympics the Ice Bucket
Challenge and Gangnam Style as for SCP
2590 it is back out on the roads roaming
around Birmingham Alabama continually ly
never stopping for fuel always obeying
the rules of the road occasionally
opening its trailer doors to reveal new
and bizarre findings when it comes to
beings with fearsome reputations there
are few scps that are as widely dreaded
as the hardto destroy reptile SCP 682 no
sane mortal would ever choose to face
such a creature and its overwhelming
ferocity and strength have even given
the reincarnating warrior SCP 076-2 able
pause on more than one occasion but then
again the saying aren't exactly in high
demand at the SCP Foundation or at
equivalent organizations formed for the
purpose of battling anomalous and
Supernatural entities organizations such
as the public safety devil hunters from
the popular Manga and Anime chainsaw man
count numerous peculiar individuals
among their ranks and sometimes the best
of the best are marked by a distinctive
tendency for out of the box thinking
that's putting it politely at least but
this isn't the story of some aberant
loser Freakazoid no definitely not the
heroine of this tale is none other than
the mightiest and most charismatic
future Nobel Prize winner ever to Grace
the rest of us shameful worms with her
presence the Invincible and dearly
beloved blood fiend power who just so
happens to be the Undisputed best
character in chainsaw man and of all
fiction as well it appeared to be an
unusually Boring Day At Public Safety
and for this ceni was grateful the young
woman had come to expect the absolute
worst from her job as a devil Hunter as
her assignments usually entailed facing
down hellish entities born from the very
fears of the human race while one would
think that someone who worked so
diligently in the field would have grown
numb to it all ceni still very much
retained her anxieties both on and off
the job at least all she had to do today
was file paperwork from one of the
public safety's like-minded Partners in
Supernatural management the SCP
Foundation it was a safe and harmless
task aside from the risk of paper cuts
and the associated potential for the
paper cut devil to show up even so ceni
would do her best to make this rare
moment of Peace last as long as possible
a voice cried from down the hallway oh
no not her keni thought why is she even
at work today she's a fighter for
division 4 and she's not good at
anything else loud exaggerated footsteps
rang out through the hallway as the
blood fiend stomped through the offices
of Public Safety keni wanted to shrink
until she vanished from sight or let
herself sink into the floor her desire
to not have to see Power today was so
great that she contemplated opening a
window and climbing down the side of the
building to the ground floor please
don't come this way ceni was still
carrying a heavy stack of freshly filed
paperwork and she didn't want her
tireless efforts at organization to go
to waste she looked frantically at the
cabinets in the storage room she was in
hoping to find enough space for her to
crawl into and make herself scarce but
it was too late power slammed open the
door of the storage room and announced
her presence the shock was so great that
ceni screamed and flung the stack of SCP
Foundation papers all over the ground
she clutched her fast Beating Heart
unable to attend to the mess immediately
ceni hadn't had to experience a fright
that sudden since the time that she was
sent to hunt the jump scare devil the
poor girl could never have a surprise
party thrown in her honor again Drew to
her name power immediately reprimanded
ceni for dropping the papers stating
that her workmanship was sloppy and that
power herself could easily carry 10
times the amount of paper kui tried to
not let the chiding of her coworker
affect her mood she bent down and
scooped up the papers but much to her
Chagrin power decided to help with this
task as well the blood fiend began
grabbing the papers and stacking them as
as assertively as possible on the
nearest surfaces resulting in many
crumpled edges and uneven piles ceni
attempted albeit hesitantly to correct
Po's paper collection method only to be
met with more scorn GOI nearly cried
this was just too much for her to handle
especially on what was supposed to be a
calm day that was when power picked up
one of the files and began to read it
was a record of the infamous cross test
between SCP 682 and SCP 076 6-2 since
Public Safety had previously assisted
the foundation in recontain SCP 076-2
there had been an agreement to send
copies of all relevant documents
involving Abel over to Japan in case of
another incident as power struggled
through the scientific language and
specifics she began to Envision her own
version of the events that played out on
the page she imagined herself as able
facing off in pitched combat against SCP
682 and giving the Terrible lizard a run
for its money in the process in the mere
seconds it took for power to finish
reading the document she had not only
concocted an entire epic battle in mind
but was not fully convinced that her
fantasy was indistinguishable from one
of her own lived experiences in her head
power had definitely fought against SCP
682 and she'd do it again in a heartbeat
just to teach that overgrown reptile
another lesson power asked ceni if she
had ever told her about the time that
the blood fiend had totally defeated as
CP 682 ceni still clutching to her
increasingly frail understanding of
reality responded with confusion what
was she talking about nobody in public
safety had fought against an SCP other
than 076-2 there was no possible way
that power was telling the truth but the
scariest part was power herself didn't
even know that she was lying the blood
fiend began to relate the sorid details
of her pulse pounding fight with SCP 682
to ceni in great detail keni for her
part was too emotionally drained at this
point to try and stop her it all started
at the bowling alley Where power was
hanging out with her much less
intelligent friends Aki and denji the
blood fiend had just finished winning
her fifth perfectly scored game in a row
when some shady characters a few lanes
over decided to cause some trouble the
leader of this little gang was none
other than SCP 682 the way you bow is
disgusting the troublemaking lizard said
this wicked remark would not be stood
for not in the proud bowling
establishment that power had founded
with her own money and achieved several
years of successful business running
herself the bowling alley was a pillar
of the community and she was the owner
there would be no further disrespect on
her watch power put up her dukes and got
ready to bring the pain down on SCP 682
Aki and denji were too terrified to help
her out as usual but did their best to
cheer their lead later on from the
sidelines SCP 682 also dismissed its
minions and qued forward like the big
ugly lizard that it was it obviously
didn't know better which is why it
wasn't backing down in the face of the
greatest devil hunter that the world had
ever known either way this would be a
Brawl for the ages rather than cause
damage to her beloved place of business
power suggested that she and her
opponent took this fight outside despite
its uncouth demeanor the reptile had a
healthy appr appreciation for the fine
sport of bowling and most especially
this particularly excellent run
five-star bowling alley it agreed to
step outside in the interest of not
bringing bowling into this intensely
personal Grudge Match but then again
wasn't the fight about bowling no matter
power and SCP 682 walked outside the
bowling alley into a vast trackless
Wasteland the perfect place for both of
them to go all out without hurting any
civilians using her ability to control
and reshape her own blood power
constructed an enormous Crimson Mallet
that she was able to wield gracefully in
both her hands despite its incredible
size SCP 682 readied itself it had faced
many different kinds of humanoid weapon
wielders before including Abel but it
was too clever of an adversary to let
its guard down especially because in
this case the blood fiend it was
fighting was a remarkable businesswoman
and an Olympic gold medalist in
everything the reptile certainly let it
scarred down power held the hammer above
her head and jumped High into the air if
she wanted to she could have circled the
globe in a single leap but out of
respect for the fact that SCP 682 was a
paying customer at her establishment she
decided to hold back for the first
attack at least nonetheless she brought
the hammer down on the hard to destroy
reptile with Supreme Force SCP 682
smashed into the ground with such a
force that a crater opened up beneath
its body the reptile itself didn't seem
especially damaged but the effects on
the surrounding environment were
certainly dramatic and fitting for an
Ultimate Showdown SCP 682 shook off the
blow and pounced on power with such
ferocity that even she couldn't remain
on her feet she tumbled back into the
dust and debris of the Wasteland for
several miles before catching herself
and standing back up remarkably there
wasn't even a scratch on her she pointed
and laughed at SCP 682 mocking it for
its weakness and stupidity the reptile
grinned wickedly and responded with a
mocking laugh of its own the creature
had intentionally taken a hit from power
in order to better understand her
fighting moves who wouldn't want to
steal those masterful techniques after
all they're just too good to resist
making a cheap copy of and from what
power could remember from her speed read
of the file that appeared to be SCP 682s
whole thing soon a bing of blood red
armor appeared around
scp-682's body in the short time CL that
it had been fighting Power it had
clearly learned how to manipulate its
own blood and was now even stronger for
it now I'm as strong as you I can't lose
SCP 682 barked at Power she swung her
Mallet in a show of force the two
combatants now both wielding the near
Limitless powers of the blood fiend
charged at each other across the
battlefield this was not just a mere
sparring match anymore it was a fight
for the fade of the entire world
snapping back to reality Po's retelling
of the story had devolved into a series
of random exclamations and sound effects
ceni was now finding the events
incredibly hard to follow but thankfully
she had been able to use power's highly
distractable mannerisms to finish
restacking the files from the foundation
not a minute too soon either as both she
and power's boss Mima stepped into the
storage room apparently makima was in
the process of doing a headcount of all
employees who had come into work today
as any normal and benevolent Superior
would she had been looking for cenan
power for some time now and was
surprised to find them here of all
places cabi explained that she had been
putting away the last of the SCP
Foundation files and would gladly accept
whatever new post she was given but
Power wasn't done with her current SCP
682 Fascination and turned to Maka
hoping to be encouraged to continue the
story Maka simply smiled and implied
that if power was so inclined to settle
her score with a hard to destroy reptile
Public Safety could get in contact with
the foundation and have her on a flight
to site 19 by that evening power
suddenly realized that she had come down
with a terrible case of whatever
crippling disease that would be a
sufficient excuse for her to not do that
Mima nodded and encouraged her
subordinates to return to work the man
sprinted through the hallways of site 01
as fast as he could bullets whizzed over
his shoulders as Panic shouts went up
all around him the whole facility was
bathed in red head as Security Alarms
deafened his ears he had to move fast
had to get out of here before it was too
late a force smacked him in the back so
hard that he fell onto his face skitting
across the vinyl floor planting both
hands on the ground and trying to push
himself back up he felt his right
shoulder blade creaking and bending
against itself he'd been shot enough
times in his life to know what a bullet
shattered bone felt like trying his best
to ignore the pain washing through his
body he kept running more bullets hit
him in his torso his shoulders his arms
and his neck one even caught the top of
his skull slicing a clear line through
his hair but he kept running the doors
were slowly closing in front of him as
the foundation Personnel swarmed the
hallways all he had to do was make it to
those doors slide through the Gap and
he'd be free if only they could
understand if only all the agents
researchers and the overseer council
could make sense of what he was telling
them they would let him go through these
doors instead of trying to shoot him
down like a dog just 10 ft to go he was
nearly there when a bullet ripped
through his calf and sent him tumbling
to the ground again but this time before
he could get up a rain of bullets washed
through his body igniting a pain so
Fierce that he wished it could all just
be over but it never was the pile of
pitiful remains was wheeled back into a
containment cell with a door locked
behind it you would think the body lying
on the floor was some kind of roadkill
but it was in fact a man a man whose
body slowly and painfully over the
course of 4 months pushed every one of
the 247 bullets out of itself and got to
work stitching itself back together as
he lay there weeping on his own Andrea
Twain had been head hunted by the
foundation while she was still in
college sitting in a Harvard Library
she'd been hard at work on her thesis
pouring hour after hour into researching
jellyfish she was starting to see them
in her sleep and she was falling falling
asleep at her desk quite a lot fueled by
energy drinks and cups of coffee it was
starting to seem like the jellyfish were
floating all around her between the
bookshelves that's why when she was
approached by Foundation operatives
offering her a place studying the most
top secret entity on the planet she was
pretty sure it was all in her head but
then 6 months later and living in a
facility that she didn't even know the
location of it started to Dawn on her
the gravity of the task she had been
handed her research topic had been the h
rosian turritopsis dorai a small
jellyfish with the power to reverse the
aging process dubbed the immortal
jellyfish she had been right on the
verge of cracking what was the creatures
genetic makeup that made it able to
produce cells younger than those that
they were replacing a feat that could
cure all number of human diseases and
revolutionize medicine and society as we
know it but standing at the window in
sight 01 and looking through the glass
at SCP 001 Andrea realized that all of
her research had barely scratched the
surface of what was possible on the
other side of the window sat SCP 001 to
many this SCP was probably very
disappointing to look at it wasn't a
giant reptile it couldn't teleport
around the facility it didn't even have
any visible powers or really anything to
distinguish it from any of the other
researchers sitting on the other side of
the glass it looked entirely like a
regular human male it was housed in a
standard humanoid containment cell with
no added security features it was
sustained on a standard humanoid meal
program Three Square meals a day with
the correct number of calories nutrients
and vitamins if anything SCP 001
probably had a more balanced diet than
Andrea herself did some researchers have
questioned the need for feeding this SCP
it was Immortal totally unkillable and
resistant to aging it had been burned
alive drowned in acid and beat to a pulp
and yet very slowly it would always
recover so why did they feed it if they
didn't it would get quite grumpy more
than anything in the world Andrea was
desperate to talk to it containment
procedures were very strict around this
SCP there would be no contact beyond the
delivery of meals no conversations no
sign language nothing it would sit by
itself alone in silence and three times
a day a meal would be placed in front of
it by a researcher who would promptly
leave the reason SCP 001 could PR
predict the future initial Research into
this SCP found that it had an uncanny
ability to describe events that had not
yet occurred despite having no exposure
to the outside world it could predict an
entire season of Major League Baseball
right down to the individual player
performances it foretold the fall of the
Berlin Wall the Chernobyl meltdown 911
the crash of the housing market and
countless other events in 2004 a
careless researcher asked SCP 001 what
the weather was looking like like SCP
001 proceeded in detail to describe
Hurricane Katrina from its formation
through to the humanitarian response and
the political Fallout a full year before
any of those events unfolded the
foundation has tried and failed to use
these predictions in order to prevent
tragedies from occurring but due to
ironic twists of Fate any attempts to
prevent these predictions from coming
true often wind up fulfilling them in
the case of Chernobyl agents who were
deployed Ed into the Soviet Union to
work in the power plant itself wound up
making critical blunders that led to the
reactor's Meltdown if the foundation had
not gotten involved the accident would
have been averted that said taking a
passive approach does not appear to be
an effective countermeasure either it
seems that whatever SCP 001 predicts
that course of history becomes
inevitable how could you not want to
talk to such an entity as Andrea stood
at the glass watching it she knew she
had to hatch a plan the foundation may
not be able to prevent these tragedies
from occurring but surely they would
want to know what's going to happen they
were researchers after all and their job
was to discover information predicting
the future that was the most valuable
information of all but it went deeper
than that if anything the predictions of
the future were a byproduct in Andrea's
mind there was something suspicious
going on with this SCP something that
the foundation was trying its best to
keep under WRA app she had seen it in
the classified documents files left out
on desks that should have been locked
away securely security and procedure had
grown LAX with the monotony of
containing this SCP in these files were
interview Snippets a chance for this SCP
to reveal who it truly was at the start
of the first interview Dr Lynch simply
pleasantly greeted SCP 001 he replied
your daughter will be hit by a bus
before her 7th birthday I can tell you
the specific day if you'd like the
interview session was paused as Dr Lynch
grew distressed and had to leave his
post to go and spend time with his
family the interview resumed under Dr
Goldstein who asked SCP 001 why he felt
the need to give such distressing
information to Dr Lynch he replied I
have told you people countless times
before you were not to refer to me as
scp1 I am the founder of this
organization and you will address me as
such when Dr Goldstein questioned that
assertation SC PP 001 replied you really
don't believe everything they have on
file do you address me as founder or I
will tell you about what your husband is
up to Dr Goldstein things collapsed very
quickly after that Andrea's plan started
as so many great plans do with her
sprinkling a chemical compound over one
of her colleagues Cheerios it was
nothing poisonous well at least not that
poisonous but it would put him out of
action for a few months long enough for
her to assume his position Andrea had
been next in line for a while to take
over the role of meal deliveries for SCP
001 and as her fellow researcher
violently vomited into a bucket in the
corner of their office she knew that her
time had come with the plastic tray in
her hands loaded with some kind of beige
slop and an apple she waited in the
doorway ready for the seals to hiss and
the door to slide slowly open for her
she stepped into the room trembling she
had expected the air in here to be stale
breathed and rebreathed for decades by
the same man but of course it had been
expertly filtered and purified by the
Foundation Systems the air in here was
as clean and balanced as it had been on
the other side of the glass the founder
looked up at her as she walked towards
him she would be a new face to him
something he hadn't seen for the prior 5
years his eyes dug into her showing no
surprise at all she suddenly realized
that of course he wouldn't be shocked to
see someone new he could see the future
he knew that she was coming suddenly
unsure of herself she wondered what
Elsie knew about her future about her
most closely guarded secrets about
whether her plan would work at all
Andrea placed the meal in front of him
silently knowing that the cameras and
microphones were all paying close
attention to her subtly as she could she
nodded at SCP 001 turned around and left
the room Andrea's heart hammered as she
sat back down on the other side of the
glass with her colleagues her entire
plan hinged on one thing monotony all of
the checks all of the vigilance all the
scrutiny that had been poured into scp1
for decades had to have Faded by now
faded just enough for the person
watching the security cameras not to
notice one word etched into the plastic
tray as as CP 001 took its spoonful of
food now as CP 001 launched from its
chair and sprinted towards the door in
the corner of the room before any of the
other researchers could react Andrea
slammed a hand on the open door button
there was a hissing sound and the SCP
was free from its containment cell
confused voices filled the room yelling
over one another in utter confusion they
had all been so caught off guard that
none of them had paid attention to what
had just happened before they had time
to put the pieces together Andrea was
out of the door herself running down the
corridor there was just one door between
her and the SCP she ran over to key in
the security code to open the door and
let the SCP out but before she could
even touch the keypad a bullet caught
her in the chest and she collapsed to
the ground wheezing a scared security
agent stared at her wide-eyed what have
you done he exclaimed then both of them
turned to look at the locked door
waiting Andrea Twain had not wanted to
let the SCP out until she saw one
specific line from an interview tape SCP
001 referring to itself as the founder
explained in patient detail how it was
entirely supportive of the foundation's
goals motivations and actions it had no
intention of intervening with any of
their work it explained that all of
their ideas were in fact its own as it
was the one who had created the
foundation in the first place but there
was something coming a prediction that
SCP 001 refused to speak out loud under
any circumstances it had just one
request that it would repeat to every
interviewer for decades after decade
they had to free it so it could prevent
that event from happening it must be
allowed to construct a device otherwise
while it actually never explains that
part neither does it explain what this
device is and Point Blank refuses to
allow another to build this device in
its stead due to the unpredictability of
what would happen if SC SCP 001 was
allowed to construct this device the
overseer Council has Point Blank refused
to entertain the notion but Andrea just
couldn't shake it from her mind this SCP
was capable of accurately and precisely
predicting all number of future events
right down to the granular detail
no matter how tragic and how dark yet
there was an unknown in its future it
didn't know whether it would be released
or not it had to beg for its freedom
whatever it needed this device to defeat
was clearly so powerful that it went
beyond sccp 001's capacity to predict
and understand it there was an event
coming that was so significant that it
created chaos and uncertainty in SCP
001's perfect view of the future and
there was only one entity that Andrea
trusted to be powerful enough to
counteract this event and as she lay
there dying in a pool of her own blood
she looked up through the glass window
in the door at the entity she trusted
and watched as it keyed in the passcode
to the door the door slid open and the
SCP took off running along the hallway
with her dying breaths Andrea told the
SCP the passco to the door that it had
just opened understanding the Brilliance
of what had just happened the SCP had
been able to open that door because it
had seen the future where she told it
the password and with that she smiled
and laid her head down on the hard floor
except SCP 001 did not manage to escape
it was gunned down in the hallway with
247 bullets that brutalized its body and
was wheeled back into its containment
cell where it began the slow process of
healing for most of the research team
things went back to business as usual
albeit with slightly better security but
to the handful of researchers who really
thought about what had happened a sense
of unease settled on their shoulders SCP
001 would have known before it ran out
of that cell and attempted Andrea's plan
that its Escape was going to fail it
would have known decades prior to the
exact positions of the 247 bullets that
pounded into its body it would have
known the Searing Agony that it would
have to endure for months as its body
slowly healed from its failed escape
attempt and yet it had gone through with
it anyway what set of events had been
put into motion when Andrea carved those
three letters into the plastic tray what
greater purpose was SCP 001 working
towards and was it now too late to stop
it if you have ever taken a trip to
suntop mountain in the Mount Baker snow
kwami National Forest Washington State
then you may have come across an old
wooden structure the suntop fire lookout
built in the early 1930s the building
was used by the US Forest Service to
keep watch for any fires in the nearby
Woodland at one point suntop fire
lookout would have been ma 365 days a
year complete with a bed for staff who
were stationed there on rotation the
singl story Lookout house overlooks the
scenic valleys of the White River and
Huckleberry Creek but you're not here
for an informative tourist guide you
probably don't care about the frankly
fascinating history of the lookout and
how it was used as part of the aircraft
warning service during World War II
watching for enemy planes no you're here
because something much darker lurks
inside the suntop fire lookout and even
though it appears to be a simple
one-story tall wooden structure it
certainly is not short on Space SCP 3333
refers to an anomaly that the foundation
discovered inside the suntop fire
lookout house the building's interior is
a single Square Room measuring 14 ft by
14 ft with large windows on all four
sides when standing inside suntop fire
lookout looking up at the wooden ceiling
one will immediately notice a trap door
no big deal right a lot of places have a
ceiling entrance to a small crawl space
there's probably nothing behind that
trapo apart from a Dusty old attic
there's a latch that maybe once had a
padlock there but not anymore opening
the trap door will reveal a collapsible
ladder should anyone be brave or indeed
foolish enough to begin to climb then
they'll soon find themselves right back
where they started inside suntop fire
lookout or so it will seem the thing
about being in a place like the Mount
Baker snow kwami National Forest that
surrounds suntop fire lookout is that
Woodland areas are teeming with life not
just plants and trees but birds and
other animals of the forest you can
never truly be alone in a setting like
that there is always life everywhere
around you so when you ascend the ladder
and climb right back into the suntop
fire lookout that is the first most
noticeable difference you will find it
may take a while at first but the
nagging absence of something unusually
so abundant in a forest will eventually
become obvious it's quiet far too quiet
no bird song or the sound of distant
calls from Woodland Critters just
silence all around anyone ascending the
ladder will find themselves in a copy of
suntop fire lookout's interior one story
higher than the ground level of the
small wooden building with the stairs
leading up to the front door getting
taller each time to reach up to the
higher and higher building now you know
the SCP Foundation and the types of
bizarre interdimensional anomalies that
they're used to dealing with perhaps SCP
3333 is a mirror Dimension or a plane of
existence where sound doesn't travel it
certainly seems to be identical to the
suntop fire lookout save for the lack of
any organic life outside of course it's
what you'll find living inside SCP
3333 that you may want to worry about
climbing higher up the next ladder and
through the next trapo every time with
the same result you appear at another
copy of suntop fire lookout each one
higher up than the last what first
seemed to be an innocuous unassuming
wooden building is now an endless
Ascension up into the heavens towards
the unknown in silence without a shred
of plant or animal life outside as you
climb perhaps you start to think about
how much higher these copies go this
might even be the biblical Jacob's
Ladder connecting Heaven and Earth that
would be nice wouldn't it if you were
gradually climbing your way up to
Paradise it might make it worth the trip
but SCP 3333 is nothing that Pleasant
you wouldn't be the first to attempt
this long climb when the CP Foundation
first discovered SCP 3333 a research
detail set up an on-site base camp to
examine this spatial anomaly their first
exploration involves sending a member of
d-class personnel designated d4f 68a up
the ladder his D number is a heximal
code that when translated to text reads
o so we'll call him that for brevity's
sake during the first day's exploration
o was able to climb 184 iterations of
SCP 3333 communicating with head
researcher Dr Williams Below on the
second day o could see a pair of figures
standing motionless on a nearby Ridge
but the pair could not be seen by Dr
Williams and the other researchers at
the base camp both figures disappeared
shortly after o spotted them with the
camera he had been issued and he felt
uneasy almost certain that he saw them
point at him the next day at the 345th
copy of suntop fire lookout O's Behavior
started to noticeably change previously
he had been anxious about the long climb
and hadn't questioned directions given
to him by Dr Williams now he seemed to
speak more casually resisting
instructions asking Williams to climb
back down and even calling her doc
instead of doctor o also reported seeing
writing on the walls but there was no
evidence of this on his camera it
appeared that something had started to
affect him it was when o reached level
500 27 that things seemed to change more
dramatically rather than SCP 3333
continuing upwards the copies of suntop
fire lookout no longer had a trap door
or ladder they seemed to be arranged
side by side in a grid-like pattern
stepping out of the main doorway o
remarked on the lack of sunlight and a
walkway that connected directly to the
front door of the next iteration of SCP
3333 o complained about the last of
natural light and again requested to be
allowed back down Dr Williams instructed
o to use the flashlights he was provided
but they wouldn't activate and their
spare batteries had vanished O then
noticed a sudden movement and just then
his microphone and camera feed went dead
almost as if someone had turned them off
it appeared that SCP 3333 had something
else lurking up there Dr Williams
oversaw the second Expedition into SCP
3333 this time members of mobile task
force mod zero also known by the code
name characteristic eggin spaces were
sent up the ladder there are sent
through the various copies of suntop
fire lookout were not as eventful as o's
with no signs of mysterious figures or
anxious feelings that o seemed to feel
as he climbed when they reached level
527 where the copies of the lookout
stopped progressing upwards and spread
out in a pattern instead their lights
and Equipment all seemed to be in
working order ever as the MTF team split
up one by one they encountered some sort
of anomaly or an effect of SCP 3333 that
caused each of them to vanish into the
dark either that or something took them
these MTF units reappeared confused in
Mod Five the team's leader Graham purcel
issued an order to retreat and the
entire Squad went back down the ladders
for several days until they finally
reached the base camp again the members
of mods zero were adamant they did not
wish to climb SCP 3333 again but Dr
Williams was beginning to understand
more of the anomalies of facts it
appeared to cause abrupt changes to
people's personalities along with some
sort of phenomenon that caused things to
appear and disappear The Higher One
climb assuming these were the result of
a mimetic effect Dr Williams dispatched
a counter memetic specialist for the
next Expedition this specialist was a
blind deaf and mute woman known as
Annette or the null Walker who
communicated via a signaling system
embedded in her hand but was otherwise
immune to any mimetic influences
observed by Dr Williams and Graham pcel
at base camp Anette made her way to the
top of SCP 3333 reporting that she was
aware of someone watching her from
outside the copies of suntop fire
lookout on her body camera a flicker of
motion occurred something looking
through the windows that ducked out of
frame when the camera passed in its
direction at the Apex of SCP 3333
Annette kept her flashlight off but
reported that she could detect blood
following it to what she assumed was a
body sounds of movement surrounded her
and as an nette switched on her
flashlight Williams and purcel saw that
it wasn't a body in front of her instead
it was a pile of rotting organs
decomposing muscles and discarded bones
and among the pile was a metal dog tag
that read MTF mod 5 gr per cell the same
man who was sitting next to Dr Williams
at base camp well the same man on the
outside at least the explanation for
everything going on inside SCP
3333 all these strange occurrences and
disappearances finally came in a video
sent from Dr Williams's cell phone in it
a panicked Williams covered in blood was
fleeing from something at the top of the
recursive stack of SCP 33 333 there was
no mimetic effect at the apex of the
suntop fire lookout copies nothing was
causing the people that the foundation
sent up to act unlike themselves they
simply weren't themselves anymore
according to a frantic video Dr Williams
had discovered the truth about what else
was hiding within SCP
3333 with just the right amount of
vagueness and Intrigue the research team
had been drawn in it was as if they'd
been lured in by the lights of an
anglerfish realizing their Grim fate
only too late the d-class O the MTF team
even a net had been replaced an unknown
group of entities on the top level of
SCP 3333 had been carefully observing
them waiting until they would not be
seen to slip in and switch places these
entities had been creating imagined
anomalous effects like o seeing figures
that weren't really there as a way of
luring more bodies further up the stack
they wanted the foundation to keep
sending Expeditions into SCP
3333 to keep them coming back the mass
of organs musculature and bones that an
nette had stumbled across revealing the
ruls had once belonged to gram per Cel
before he was replaced you see the
entities residing in SCP 3333 weren't
just copying people they weren't
possessing them or mind controlling them
or even shape shifting to steal a
person's likeness they were taking skin
these creatures hollowed out Graham o
Annette and the MTF team pulling out
their innards and crawling their way
inside filling these fleshy puppets and
leaving their internal organs to rot
these hollowed out people became vessels
for the entities of SCP 3333 to hide in
the whole thing had been a trap
intentionally exploiting human
weaknesses Intrigue and unanswered
questions you know what they say about
curiosity and these entities used it to
bring more potential vessels to the top
of SCP
3333 they pretended to be the people who
they had replaced imitating them so the
foundation would send more Personnel to
explore the tower increasing their
supply of skins Graham Stog tag had
revealed the deception and Dr Williams
had escaped up SCP 3333 the members of
the research team that had already been
replaced were hot on her tail determined
to catch and Hollow her out too and by
the end of her video they had succeeded
a month later though the team delivering
supplies realized what had happened and
the trap door was sealed suntop fire
lookout was put under permanent guard
but at least 50 Personnel were killed or
replaced by one of the entities a new
mobile task force Lambda 1 Maxwell's
demons was created to hunt down and
neutralize any of the entities that had
escaped SCP
3333 but it's still unknown how many
left the tower and are still out there
somewhere waiting to use someone's
curiosity about the strange and unknown
against them it had been getting slower
the longer the days weeks months and
years went on the more time it took to
move before long before the collapse it
used to move like lightning in the blink
of a human eye it could go from one side
of a room to the other it had moved with
such speed that it looked to have
disappeared from one place and
reappeared in another by the time the
same human's eye reopened there it would
be standing before them and as they
realized that they had to strain to keep
their eyes open and stare at it they
would wait until they inevitably had to
Blink again that was when it would
strike but now its movements were
getting sluggish it had been able to
move around of its own volition for some
time after the collapse unobserved and
thus free for the first time in a long
while yet now it was succumbing to the
one thing it couldn't move faster than
the one thing that makes dust of all
things time a sound suddenly and faintly
but undoubtedly caused by movement a
human a victim it turned to see the man
entered the room stopping still as his
gaze fell over it all it had to do was
wait the agent could barely believe his
eyes the second he'd spotted the
sculpture he'd instinctively froze to
the spot rigid with sheer Terror heart
drumming against his rib cage standing
across the room from it directly
opposite he kept himself as still as the
concrete and rear statue was the agent
knew that as long as he looked at it it
couldn't move he just had him make sure
he didn't so much as blink or at least
that's how it used to work to his horror
the agent noticed that the arm of SCP
173 started to slowly reach towards him
but how how had the sculpture an anomaly
once capable of moving only while
unobserved found a way to suddenly start
reaching for this agent well for a start
that is something to do with the
particular Foundation operative who was
looking at SCP 173 and technically
wasn't at the same time let us start at
the beginning you see some time ago a
former field agent working at the SCP
Foundation suffered quite an
unprecedented accident let's call him
Daryl a seemingly average man in his 30s
while as average as someone working for
the foundation can be however one
Mission would unexpectedly change
Daryl's life forever turning him into
SCP
451 it start started as a
straightforward retrieval operation
Daryl was instructed to recover a
dangerous anomalous artifact however he
ultimately failed and was declared
missing an action as a result that is
until he miraculously resurfaced a month
later at site 19 but from Daryl's point
of view the entire Foundation facility
looked like it had been deserted
corridors and Labs that had previously
been bustling hives of activity were now
unsettlingly empty scps seemed to still
be in their containers Chambers but
without anyone watching or guarding them
as far as SCP 451 knew he was the only
man still alive on Earth some anomalous
influence had left him with a unique
Affliction a permanently altered
perception Daryl was rendered incapable
of seeing other human beings it wasn't
just limited to his sight either he
couldn't hear anyone or even perceive
their existence any attempts the
foundation's researchers made to
communicate with SCP 451 were
unsuccessful they could still see him
but it was like he was absent standing
just outside the real world and yet to
Daryl it was somehow worse than that
given the lack of people around him
being unable to see hear or interact
with anyone SCP 451 quickly adopted the
belief that by interacting with the
anomalous artifact he had
single-handedly wiped out the entire
human race while this wasn't true he had
no way of knowing that everyone else was
still alive he just couldn't perceive
them the guilt instilled in Daryl
weighed heavily on the agent's
conscience he spent a lot of time
wandering the corridors of site 19
overwhelmed by his apparent isolation
convinced he'd single-handedly caused
the extinction of the human race but
what does SCP 451 have to do with SCP
173 how did Daryl go from being unable
to see and hear other humans to staring
down the sculpture while while Daryl was
suffering from his newly altered
perception something catastrophic was
unfolding in The Wider world he could
hardly interact with anymore an end of
the world scenario had taken place and
left barely any survivors making the
perceived Extinction of humanity by SCP
451 oddly prophetic something had caused
the human race to actually die out and
with nobody around who could explain
what had happened the actual how and why
were forgotten to history and even if
someone had managed to survive SCP 451
would still be as oblivious to their
explanations as he was to the disaster
that claimed the lives of not only the
whole SCP Foundation but the rest of the
world too of course without the
foundation and its Personnel around any
longer to safeguard the rest of humanity
or even anything left of humanity for
them to protect things quickly got even
worse
the various contained scps soon found
themselves free to run a muck whatever
had wiped the human race from existence
left the world mostly uninhabited and it
didn't take long for some of the more
aggressive anomalies to turn on each
other with no humans for them to pray on
they had to make do but while they
fought killed and died in the ruins of
the world one was left to roam Freer
than it had ever been SCP 173 now that
the sculpture was no longer caged by the
foundation it could move around
unobserved before it would be frozen in
place when ever Personnel entered its
cell to clean it every 2 weeks
constantly watching it to stop it from
moving but now there were no Personnel
after the human race had been wiped out
SCP 173 set about bursting free from its
container it took quite some time using
its heavy concrete and rebar arms to
Dent the walls from within continually
pounding ing on the metal until it
eventually gave way bursting free SCP
173 found itself in a world with hardly
anyone around to look at it and that
meant it could go anywhere it wanted do
anything it pleased so long as none of
the other surviving scps came across it
that did happen from time to time of
course any of the more humanoid
anomalies that were capable of sight
would sometimes stumble upon the
sculpture but they had to bling sometime
and when they did as CP 173 would
effortlessly zip over to where they
stood and break their necks exercising
its Newfound Freedom SCP 173 moved
unnoticed to the office of Dr alto clef
the INF famously unhinged Foundation
researcher weapons fanatic and
specialist in decommissioning
scps clef like the rest of the human
race was nowhere to be found when the
sculpture burst into his office if it
had the capacity for for emotions maybe
it felt angered even cheated to find
that kleft was gone it had seemed to
have come seeking revenge for a number
of years Dr cleff had been infatuated
with SCP 173 were he still alive cleff
himself would have described the
anomalous statue as a former flame
someone he had a bond with although he
had no idea how one-sided his feelings
truly were the sculpture if it could
feel would have been indifferent towards
the crazed researcher were it not for
date night cleff had on a number of
occasions dressed as CP 173 and a black
dress and a blonde wig and shared
romantic evenings in its company it's
never been known if SCP 173 is just an
object with anomalous movement
Properties or if the sculpture is an
actual living creature with sentience
but if it was then no doubt being made
to go on repeated dates with Dr clef
would have humiliated SCP 173 and as it
searched clef's office while it couldn't
find the loathsome researcher it did
find a certain black dress and wig that
the sculpture quickly crushed under the
weight of its heavy Stony arms it wasn't
Dr kleff being smashed but it was enough
meanwhile SCP 451 still remained
completely unaware that everyone else
was gone to him nothing had changed he
still couldn't perceive anyone not that
there was anyone around anyway he'd
witness a lot of Destruction unfurled by
the anomalous breaking their containment
but most didn't pay darl any mind ones
that did quickly found they couldn't
interact with him or cause the former
Foundation agent harm and quickly lost
interest in him that was an added
torturous part of SCP 41's condition he
couldn't die a long time before the end
of the world scenario Daryl had found a
firearm belonging to another member of
foundation Personnel in the main main
break room of site 19 as SCP 451 tried
to fire the weapon the bullet ricocheted
off the wall and the gun shot passed
directly through him the same bullet
mortally wounded another nearby member
of foundation's staff and it was after
he'd accidentally injured this
unsuspecting researcher that SCP 451
found he was briefly able to interact
with them right as the researcher's life
was fading that was the last time he'd
been able to see anyone while any human
anyway but then he encountered SCP
173 the pair of them came face to face
with each other in the ruins of a
foundation sight by that point the
overwhelming loneliness of believing
himself to be Humanity's Soul Survivor
had already taken a bad toll on Daryl he
was losing himself every day getting
more and more overwhelmed by the
anomalous hell he was living SCP 173 was
caught for a moment when SCP 451 one
walked in on it stuck fast like it had
been whenever someone observed it but as
Daryl stared and tried not to Blink the
sculpture found itself still able to
move it could see SCP 451 and he could
see it yet it could still move somehow
due to the way Daryl's perception had
been anomalously altered it affected the
way he saw the sculpture it was almost
like he was seeing it without seeing it
had been so long since Humanity
disappeared that the sculptures
movements had been gradually getting
slower the rebar holding it together had
been rusting creaking more as it bent
and twisted its concrete parts were
starting to crumble away and now despite
being free it was struggling just to
reach an arm out to SCP 451 to kill him
for his part SCP 451 had been forced to
live out a painful existence spending
each and every day alone as delirium had
begun to sink its claws into him Daryl
had wished for one thing some company
and now he'd found it misinterpreting
scp1 73's arm extending towards him SCP
451 broke down crying and embraced the
sculpture his tears ran down the
anomalous statue's decaying concrete
body the struts in its arms creaking as
it tried to reach for Daryl but the
sculpture was getting old too old to
kill as quick as it used to time and
loneliness two of the most painful
things to experienced the side effect of
and yet while SCP 173 continued to
wither it was unknowingly helping
alleviate someone else's pain although
it could still move while SCP 451 looked
at it Daryl didn't leave the sculpture
alone in his mind driven half mad by
being isolated for so long he genuinely
believed that SCP 173 and he were
friends the sculpture had spared him
after all SCP 451 had no idea what had
happened to the rest of the human race
and the other scps now loose on the
world barely acknowledged him but in the
concrete and rebar statue he found a
friend SCP 451 followed SCP 173 as it
shuffled itself away not leaving its
side matching the slowed speed of its
Stony scraping movements as they
wandered together Daryl poured his heart
out about everything and anything glad
to have someone anyone to talk to even
if the sculpture couldn't reply again
nobody knows for sure if SCP 173 was an
object or a living creature but if it
was the latter then there's still no
telling how it perceived as SCP 451 it
could have taken pity on him maybe
sympathizing with his plight and
begrudgingly alleviating his Solitude or
it might have found Daryl to be a
nuisance we'll never know and neither
would SCP 451 as the years pass pass as
CP 173 continued to slow down and kept
withering portions of its concrete body
crumbled until they were little more
than dust the metal wired through the
sculpture rusted eventually coming to a
stop what was left of s SCP 173 stopped
moving fixed to one spot where it would
stay forever still not realizing it had
perished as CP 451 sat beside it and
kept talking the booming steps echoed
through the museum corridors pharaohs
Emperors and Mongolian War leaders all
stood stock still as the terrified
security guard ran between them Roger
Pascal swung his flashlight this way and
that the light glinted on the polished
steel of ancient Weaponry muskets
scimitars and cannons exhibit after
exhibit flashed past him as he ran
through the dark Museum there was no way
it was real no possible way he was
having a bad dream that's all it was a
bad dream the shaking ground under his
feet and the marching Rhythm of the
impossibly heavy footsteps behind him
told him that it was real all right it
had just been a normal shift like any
other just a regular Night at the Museum
Roger had been sipping his coffee and
listening to the radio when all of a
sudden he felt his chair start rumbling
beneath him he put his coffee down on
the table and watched as it recoiled as
the footsteps grew louder and closer he
got up to investigate and couldn't
believe what he'd walked in on skitting
around the corner he tumbled into a
medieval suit of armor and sent it
crashing across the floor chain mail
helmet gauntlets all of it rattled and
crashed to the marble floor echoing all
through the museum then there was a
sudden deathly silence as the footsteps
stopped Roger didn't breathe then they
started again heading straight toward WS
him it was all Roger could do to lie on
his back in front of the giant Taxidermy
eagle and point his flashlight at the
door as the Monstrous figure of the
stone Soldier walked around the corner
musket in hand Woodstock Vermont
1995 it was a normal day just like any
other the birds were singing in the
trees and there was a gentle breeze
blowing through nothing at all out of
the ordinary except of course the statue
that opened its eyes the civil war
memorial had been a staple of Woodstock
for well over 100 Years A plinth sitting
in the middle of a park with a young
Soldier on top of it holding a musket
peacefully by his side the statue had
watched over the town generation after
generation except now its watching had
become a little more active it took
several hours for anyone to notice dog
walkers went pass listening to their
walkman's a banker sat on a bench
opposite deep in conversation on a giant
brick phone it was only when a young
child running after her football looked
up at the Statue and saw it looking back
at her that things changed the girl's
parents didn't listen to her of course
parents rarely do but word quickly went
around the girl's school most of the
time the statue was totally still no
movement in the eyes at all but on
occasion when a group of kids gathered
around it and talked to it enough the
statue seemed to look down at them as if
it was listening but that was it no
grown-ups were particularly interested
in what the children were saying and
even a lot of the children who saw it
went home concluding that they must have
been imagining things so 6 months went
by without anyone really paying the
statue much attention that was until it
fired its gun in a quiet rural Town
everyone hears a gunshot but for a long
time no one could work out where it had
come from police gathered around the
park searching all around where the
weapon had been h heard the only clue
they could find was a small hole in the
wall of a shop across the street a
couple of officers joked that the shot
must have come from the statue itself
everyone laughed it off except for a
couple of the school kids who were
playing nearby less than 2 weeks later
another shot rang out in the middle of
the night and a group of confused police
officers rushed to the park to
investigate what had happened the only
thing they found was a dead bird lying
on the sidewalk shot to death again the
jokes went around the department that it
must have been the statue who did it
except this time the officers were all
laughing a little less
enthusiastically without much crime
going on in Woodstock Vermont the
department decided to take the shooting
quite seriously going so far as to
perform an autopsy on the dead pigeon
but when they cut the animal open and
looked at the wound inside its chest
they were filled with even more
confusion than they were before it
wasn't a conventional bullet launched
into the bird's rib cage at all it was
perfectly round and made of what
appeared to be Stone but the next shot
that rang out from the Memorial Park was
unmistakable it was a weekend in the
middle of the summer vacation so the
park was full of families all sitting
around having picnics barbecues and
staring up at the sky watching the birds
Circle lazily overhead bang one of the
pigeons exploded in a burst of feathers
and plummeted out of the sky landing on
the sidewalk in front of the whole town
in in shock all the town's folk turned
around to see the stone statue down on
one knee with his musket on his shoulder
the statue looked down at all of them
surprised at the attention then quickly
got back to its feet and resumed its
normal stance reports flooded all the
local papers and news stations the event
was blamed on mass hysteria a kind of
group hallucination where everyone was
somehow sharing the same story but the
number of people coming forward with the
exact same account was irrefutable
evidence that's where the foundation had
to step in in January 1996 containment
procedures began and the statue was
given the designation SCP 011 of course
a large contingent of Agents suddenly
appearing in a small town would raise a
lot of Suspicion so the foundation had
to move very cautiously One agent at a
time the foundation established itself
in Woodstock and began to study the
statue day in and day out by sitting on
park benches even looking through cutout
holes in newspapers and wearing fake
outfits so as not to arouse suspicion
steadily over time the statue appeared
to gain either a heightened Mobility or
just a renewed sense of confidence while
much of the time it did remain standing
immobile it would begin to occasionally
stretch when it thought no one was
looking and glanced this way and that in
apparent annoyance with the birds
circling over its head the shooting
steadily grew more regular Foundation
agents observed several birds being
picked out of the sky by the musket fire
of SCP 011 over the following weeks a
clear pattern started to emerge the
statue would only fire at birds that
seem to be flying above it or getting
too curious about it in fact the more
feal matter built up on the Statue the
more aggressive it would be both in its
body language and mood seemed to sour
the dirtier it got while there were
initial concerns about the SCP
potentially turning its rifle towards
the local towns people these worries
were largely dismissed as SCP 011
gradually started to build up a rapport
with those around it before long the
caretakers of the park were having
exchanges with the SCP these exchanges
started with the caretaker speaking
directly to the SCP ended nodding or
subtly acknowledging the things they
said but over time the interactions grew
more and more personable in the year
2000 sccp 011 spoke for the first time
it had just fired its rifle picking off
a pigeon from over 2 200 ft away when a
caretaker mildly exclaimed Nice Shot the
statue smiled dipped his hat to the
caretaker and said Thank you in a gr
voice this marked a significant change
in the foundation's approach to the
containment of SCP 011 up until this
point the SCP was considered a broadly
harmless member of the local town
community however its ability to speak
raised concerns as to this scp's
development 4 years ago it had been an
immobile statue with nothing out of the
ordinary to raise any suspicions among
those around it where would its
cognitive development end now that it
had gained the ability to talk grounders
and agents posing as grounders struck up
conversations with SCP 011 as often as
possible at first these exchanges were
brief but over time the SCP became
steadily more vocal until soon it was
engaged in intellectual debates and
sharing its views on the world with
anyone who would listen was becoming
clear that new containment measures were
needed in fact SCP 011 soon lost
interest in shooting birds or rather the
SCP was persuaded to stop shooting birds
while the prospect of having animals
defecate on it still appeared to anger
the statue the foundation was able to
explain through ideological grounds why
shooting birds was a disproportionate
response relative to the minor harm they
were doing to it Keen to engage in
philosophical and ethical discussions
this statue was very open to hearing the
foundation's viewpoint on the issue and
having sufficiently considered all sides
of the debate decided that it would in
fact be better for the well-being of all
involved if it stops shooting the birds
from the sky in return the caretakers
and Foundation agents promised to do
their best to clean it regularly and
keep the animals at Bay but with word of
this bizarre tourist attraction steadily
Gathering momentum as the age of email
began to take off the foundation decided
that it would be best to relocate SC CP
011 entirely however agents who had been
living in Woodstock for the prior 4
years were hesitant to relocate The
Entity to a test chamber or storage
facility the benefits that it had
brought to the local community far
outweighed the risks and threats that it
posed the statue had become a local
celebrity smiling and waving at children
who went past and even offering brief
history lessons to any confused tourists
who found themselves wandering through
the park most just assumed it was a
person in gray paint it was was agent KH
who came up with the idea of relocating
SCP 011 to a museum being kept indoors
away from the dangers of any fecal
bombing runs was the main priority KH
argued that within a museum the statue
would blend in seamlessly with the
exhibits around it furthermore if anyone
did see the statue move or talk they
would assume that it was an interactive
exhibit and treated as such having shown
a real love for Academia history and
debate KH believed that scp's 011 would
benefit greatly from being in such a
setting both learning and eventually
even teaching about the history of the
American Civil War however when all
these arguments were put forward to the
Statue itself it was hesitant having
spent the entirety of its cognitive
existance standing on the same plinth
shooting at the same pigeons the idea of
relocating to somewhere new and unknown
was very intimidating even with the
solders mindset SCP 011 was still
feeling incredibly nervous about the
idea of moving house agent con and SCP
011 found themselves locked in a
stalemate try as she might convincing
the SCP to leave its current home was
like talking to a brick wall or rather a
stone wall the pair of them ended up
dropping the conversation for a couple
years focused instead on psychiatric
evaluations and history lessons for the
SCP in 2002 the foundation officially
declared that SCP 011 had achieved
sentience with a great enough level of
self-awareness to pass as a normal human
being aside from the fact that it was
composed entirely of stone for 2 years
agent con talked to SCP 011 every day on
the Park Bench the slots on the bench
had to be replaced several times as the
weight of the statue broke through them
snapping them clean in half on several
occasions during this period the pair of
them built up a rapport rarely seen
between humans and scps so much so that
in 2004 agent con managed to convince
SCP 011 to move to a local Museum on one
condition she would go as well the
foundation agreed to the terms deciding
that KH could take on the role of being
a researcher in the museum that way she
could keep an eye onp 011 and Report any
activities while the foundation
officially relinquished control over the
SCP what happened next was perhaps
rather predictable or at least it would
be predictable to anyone who had worked
with agent con and and SCP 011 during
that time in Vermont as the pair of them
moved into their new lives at the Museum
romantic feelings blossomed between them
seeing as SCP 011 is officially outside
of the SCP foundation's jurisdiction
there has been no official inquiry into
the nature and practicalities of the
relationship between the woman and the
statue but from the reports that make
their way to the foundation every 3
months it is clear that both are very
much enjoying the privacy of their new
Arrangement Roger Pascal closed his eyes
Imagining the barrel raising higher and
higher until it was pointed squarely at
his face he had been told by his bosses
not to ask questions about the origins
of the statue that had suddenly appeared
in the Civil War section even when he
saw the statue's eyes moving he'd kept
his mouth shut that was until he was
doing his security rounds that night and
heard those booming footsteps leading
him behind one of the displays he had
rushed over in a panic peering around
the corner he had been shocked to see
Miss KH one of the researchers here and
the Civil War statue engaged in a
passionate kiss he had turned and bolted
as fast as he could until he ended up
here terrified on the floor as he
imagined the musket being leveled at him
but then a second pair of footsteps
joined the group and a woman's laugh
filled the room opening his eyes the
security guard saw the pair of them the
statue and the researchers standing in
the doorway laughing about the whole
situation the musket was slung over the
and shoulder as he offered a cold Stony
hand down to the security guard to help
him up ironically there was something
about the statue's smile that softened
Roger's Stony heart as he was hauled to
his feet I have so many questions now
check out SCP 173 origin story how 173
got to site 19 and SCP 1913 deadly
Monster Squad the furies